good morning
welcome to this mid-suffolk overview and
scrutiny committee meeting
i'm councillor keith wellam and i'm
chairing the meeting today
my first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distance from all other persons in the
chamber and in the social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking or if you are
unable to do so
and that you use the hand sanitizer and
wipes provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting and during any
breaks
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
thank you i now ask the government the
governance officer to indicate who apart
from the committee are in attendance
today
thank you
thank you chair the officers we have in
attendance are catherine steele
assistant director for corporate
resources rebecca hewitt assistant
manager financial accountant
gavin fisk assistant director for
housing sean coulter senior finance
business partner hra and gf revenue
janis movies finance business partner
and cassandra clements assistant
director for environmental environment
and commercial
we also have the cabinet member for
finance john whitehead the cabinet
member for housing living near
haddingham the cabinet member for
environment just counselor jessica
fleming and we also have councillor john
field
thank you very much
can i move to the agenda please
are there any apologies and
substitutions
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor terence carter and councillor
sarah mancello substituting
thank you
are there any declarations of pecuniary
or non-pecuniary interest by members
we have a hand raised uh thank you chair
um i am i need to declare that my
brother-in-law runs a taxi firm in baber
uh and i have had a conversation with um
emily yul uh to say that i just need to
declare it because he's no intention of
moving to mid-suffolk
thank you
have we received any notifications of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received
and are there any questions by the
public
none received thank you and are there
any questions by councillors none
received thank you
so can we now
turn to
item mos 21-1
the draft general fund
2022-23 and the four-year outlook
i'd like to invite the assistant
director for corporate resources
catherine steele to make a short
presentation and to introduce her report
thank you
thank you chair
i would just like to invite actually the
cabinet member for finance to do a short
introduction before we get into the the
detail of the
so so if i could hand over to councillor
whitehead first thank you
thank you chairman um for inviting me to
the soviet scrutiny committee providing
both myself and the finance team with
the opportunity to present this draft
general fund 2223 budget to the
committee
as a report included within your report
pack sets out to explain we've
streamlined the budget setting for this
coming year and this is now an
opportunity for the opium scrutiny to
challenge the assumptions and look at
the risks associated with the budget
proposals i look forward to hearing
members observations and concerns
we have prepared a powerpoint
presentation which i trust will provide
significant further detail and analysis
of the draft budget to aid members
understanding
we intend to run through this as a very
interactive session with questions and
answers as we progress through that
presentation
however before going into the
presentation i'd like to make some just
brief introductory remarks concerning
the budget
sure but
what
when the budget for this current year
2122 was developed and ultimately agreed
in full council back in february 21 we
were at the height of the cove in 19
pandemic and the future economic outcome
and the postcode 19 world was subject to
much uncertainty
resources both nationally and locally
will focus on the day-to-day issues
arising from the pandemic
although we are still some distance from
knowing what the new post-pandemic
normal will look like things are
gradually becoming clearer
a solid economic recovery appears to be
underway and unemployment has fallen
well short of the pessimistic forecasts
however inflationary pressures and
conditions are now returning and as with
previous years we only have the benefit
of knowing our local government
settlement for just one year
now given the significant consensus at
the time of the previous budget we made
the decision to then modestly increase
our castle tax precept that was despite
the strength of our financial position
and our reserves
we also set up four times one million
pounds specific reserves for the
fundings of our key priorities
and then following cross-party meetings
and discussions
projects and commitments for us this
spending
have now been agreed by the cabinet
so we've produced this new budget 2223
in its four year medium term financial
strategy starting from a baseline
assuming no council tax increases
now that seems to me a sensible base
from which to start the budget
preparation
and then when we receive the local
government settlement
just before christmas break and that
included an additional 971 000 of an
unanticipated further funding
that seemed to strengthen the case for
this approach
of course the median return financial
strategy is prepared to ensure the
medium-term sustainability of our
finances
and when this budget comes to full
council
we will decide on the level of council
tax precept for just this one coming
financial year
we do not commit ourselves to the
council beyond one year and indeed we
could not commit any future council
beyond 20 may 2023
so i'll now ask catherine the finance
team to give us their presentation and
as i said earlier i hope it's an
interactive session
we'll take questions nice as we go
through the session
and after that we'll be here to answer
any further questions from the committee
with regard to the contents of the
general fund budget report
and i look forward to listening to your
debate and the observations concerns
arise from it thank you mr chairman
thank you chair
so as just outlined by uh councillor
councillor whitehead
um
i was going to propose that we go
through a major service area at a time
because i've got a slide for each area
so i will just run through the slide and
then pause for questions or comments
after after each one if that's
acceptable uh chair there's a way
forward
i think questions yeah i think any
debate i think we'll leave that until
after we've had the full presentation
uh but any questions on each of the
slides and that would be fine thank you
thank you
with the first one just to explain to
you what the table is saying because
they will all be the same once once
we've looked at the first one
so this table is demonstrating to you
starting off on the left hand side the
budget for the current financial year
and then the columns that follow so
you've got an employee's column another
expenses column
an income one and transfers to and from
reserves they are the movements under
those headings which then get you to the
budget to 22 23
so that's the the second from the right
hand column is the the proposed budget
for next year and then the final column
on the right hand side is the movement
between the two so you can see if the
budget is either
proposed to be higher or lower than the
current financial year
so hopefully that just explains the
format of the tables that you're going
to see this morning so starting off
first of all with this one which is
communities and well-being i'll just
take you through uh the key changes for
that area
so first of all in terms of communities
you can see overall the budget is
increasing by 56 000 pounds
and that is because there is a transfer
from reserve in the current financial
year that won't be repeated in next year
that was what was agreed when the
community's team has been restructured
during the current year
but the funding obviously will transfer
across to base budget funding for next
year compared to the current financial
year
and the second one is obviously the
leisure line on here which you can see
there is quite a significant increase
from this year to next year so just to
take you through the reasons for that
first element is that within leisure and
your provider is everyone active
normally they pay for all of their
utility bills themselves
but in order for us to move them across
to a green tariff then we've actually
taken on that contract
so from next year we will actually be
making the payments for gas and
electricity for the leisure provider but
the council will be fully reimbursed
so you've got
increased costs under the other expenses
heading but you've also got increased
income coming back in from everyone
active so say that is actually neutral
that change but it's so shown in the
figures
there's also a reduction in the income
because the council used to get a
contribution from stone market high
school and that is no longer coming into
into mid-suffolk's budget
but the other main area that is causing
the increase in in next year as a
one-year increase
is that we have moved to a new 15-year
lease arrangement with everyone active
now that new lease arrangement
is resulting in a one-year payment of
175 000 pounds next year from
mid-suffolk
but after that
then everyone active do start to pay the
council income so it say is a one-year
payment of 175 000 and then for the
years beyond 22-23
there will be income that starts to come
back to to mid-suffolk
and then just finally on leisure there
are also some savings under the other
expenses column for supplies and
services and repairs and maintenance
that the council will no longer have to
pay for because of that new new
arrangement that's been entered into
with everyone active
so i'll pause at that point chair and
see if there any questions on on this
one yeah thank you councillor caston has
a question
thank you very much chairman
so with the um
heat pumps going in
at the leisure facility
have we
had calculated the difference in the
cost of heating
the facility um
the heat pumps
i just found some figures it's 3.6
pence per kilowatt hours as opposed to
14 for electricity and
over four for gas
um
[Music]
do we have to be careful with the um
do we have to be careful with this some
ledger facility that we're not
subsidizing
the facility um and
uh damaging the competitors considering
there's two other gyms
there um have we accounted for this to
in the rent
is the question
thank you for your question cancer it's
quite fortunate that i've got my my
colleague cassandra clare clements here
who this is her area so i'll ask her
perhaps to come in and answer your
question
thank you councillor casten so firstly
uh we have assumed um in the budget
figures what the uh discounted
essentially rate or the cheaper rate of
a of fuel will be for the leisure
centres in this budget of course it's
always a an assumption there is a little
fluctuation uh but it we are we're
pretty confident that we'll be there or
thereabouts in terms of what we've
budgeted for
it is cheaper actually than it would be
once you get into the heat pumps and the
the generation and the stored energy
that we can use from those um it will be
a cheaper service going forward
then in terms of your second question
the negotiation on the
cost of the lease per year took into
account a new gym that opened up um just
a a couple of years ago actually just
pre pre-covered um and so we'd
negotiated um
a break in um in payments so there was a
number of years that were going to be at
zero so
whilst uh originally when we spoke about
it we'd hope that there'd be income from
year one we renegotiated that to have a
a zero balance for for three years and
then to start being have an income into
the council of course then covered here
and we've re-looked at it again so we've
been working with everyone active to
look at what is affordable and and a
decent you know uh landlord conversation
with them about it
and what they've asked for is for us to
give one payment year one and then we
will start having income into the
council from then so they've we've been
working with them year on year to see
what's going on in stone market who the
other providers are but then also
affordability and for the gym to keep
going
thank you chairman um
actually i think
the officers answered my second question
i just wanted to understand this
reduction in income from the stone
market high school what's that about
sorry my button wasn't working um so
this was a decreased use so the school
have had uh lesser use for the the
premises so they've been doing more
stuff outdoors instead of using the
sports halls but there is a bit of
covert related um
lack of use there as well so it's meant
a reduction
i don't foresee that that's going to
increase again given that the the school
have found alternative uses but it's an
ongoing conversation with the school and
we're always really flexible with them
to make sure that we cover what they
have to do in the curriculum so that's
what we've got in for next year but it
doesn't close off conversations with
them
thank you chair um just an overall
question really i mean whilst it's
useful to have all this information in
the powerpoint today um
i don't know whether it's going to be
able to change the scrutiny committee's
outlook on the general fund budget or
not
attention please
there is an emergency in this building
please evacuate immediately
welcome back to this meeting we had a
fire
uh a fire alarm it's turned out to be a
false alarm
and so we've had to evacuate but we're
now back in the meeting
and we were
uh the point of having questions about
the um general fund budget
and if we can
if we can go to the screen that we were
looking at and counselor ed young has a
question our counselor scarf has a
question
yeah yes thank you
i started off and then obviously we had
the fire alarm um
can i just make the point i think um
whilst this presentation on um
the changes in in relation to each of
the areas that the council operates in
is extremely useful
and obviously we have in our papers the
movement
last year's budget and next year's
budget proposals we don't have a lot of
this information in our papers and uh
whilst it's always nice to be up to date
i think
certainly i would as a member of the
committee in order to make a reasonable
judgment on the budget would have
preferred that these could have at least
been emailed to us 24 hours in advance i
think we've been bombarded with figures
and this is not the first time
that this has happened and it's sort of
almost death by powerpoint presentation
and i feel as i did at
previous meetings that
i don't think it's deliberate to design
to confuse members but i think this
information would have been useful
if we'd have had it at an early
opportunity and i cannot see why we
could not have had this at least 24
hours in advance so we could actually
read it and make some you know
reasonable assumptions about it so it's
just a point of order really chat
yes thank you yeah i quite understand
that
um
it is you know quite close to the budget
setting time that we're getting this
information and it's coming in the
middle of a meeting so it is it's
difficult to take it all in
even though we've we've had the
opportunity of having some of the
background information already
um are there any i've got one
uh counseling on then i have a question
on that slide
thank you mr chairman i i have a general
question which i'm sure is going to cut
across this
presentation and all the subsequent ones
which is the following
this
looks at the budget for 2022 and 2023
and compares it to the budget for 21.22
and i see no logical reason
uh
maybe it's my background
for comparing one a new budget to an old
budget
um
for two simple reasons one is um first
we don't know what the assumptions we
might remember what the assumptions were
for the old budget but the set the new
budget may have completely different
assumptions uh contained in it so we're
not comparing apples with apples and
secondly and more importantly we nowhere
in the in in the documentation do we
have an appraisal of how we've performed
or we are performing against the
existing budget
so that we can have an understanding of
how that's fair and how that might lead
to the new budget
so for me this exercise is really rather
fraught and you know i'm finding it
difficult to see
how much value this committee can bring
to this process
yes thank you um
i understand that
um i don't think an officer wants to
comment on that or the cabinet member
apologies that the committee are finding
it hard obviously we are doing it in a
slightly different way this year because
of the the change in in approach
um so i'd hope that the presentation
would be useful to committee because
there's a lot of detail that it was very
difficult to try and put into a written
report
i take on board the the comment that if
you'd had the presentation 24 hours in
advance
yeah take that on board and that can be
born in mind for the future
just picking up the last point about um
how the information is presented
the way we budget as we do start from
the base of the current financial year
so that is the base of how we then move
to the budget for
2223 so what i was trying to to do with
the presentation was say okay this is
where we are in 2122.
these are the things that are changing
so they are the different assumptions
that are happening that then move you
through to the budget that is being
proposed for
in terms of the current financial year
i know there is a small paragraph in the
report that does talk about the the
second quarter report that was presented
to cabinet
back in december so that gave you an
idea of the performance for this
financial year but obviously all of that
detail does go into cabinet on a quarter
quarterly basis so i just gave you the
headline figures just to just to remind
you of what cabinet would have seen back
in december
council whitehead
yeah i mean i think rather than death by
powerpoint
the intention was more like budgetary
cpr trying to bring the numbers to life
but we'll we'll take it away and think
about it for the future
kirsten mansell
uh thank you um i i um i agree with um
council whitehead is i i do find it
easier to see in a sort of summary form
but uh on the subject of how we're
performing
um on this year's budget maybe i'm
misinterpreting your little table but
but i take those other columns
to mean that of the 642 000 that you
budgeted
you you've underspent on the
employees and the other expenses but
you've overspent
the 72
am i completely misinterpreting your
little table or is that how i'm meant to
be reading it
thank you councillor um
no it's a slightly different
interpretation of the table so perhaps
if i just use that one as an example
so
using the communities line so the budget
for the current financial year is the
642 000 pounds
then under the employees heading the the
15 000 in brackets means that the
employees area of this particular budget
is 15 000 less
moving into into next year so it's not a
reflection of the performance in this
financial year it's saying that
comparing next year's budget to the
current year's budget the employees line
is going to be fifteen thousand pounds
less
similarly with the other expenses
um they're going to be two thousand
pounds less than in the current
financial year
and the movement in the transfers to and
from reserves means that that adds a net
cost of 72 000 pounds
to the budget so adding the figures
across the row from the 642 take off the
15 take off the two add on the 72 gets
you to the proposed new budget of 698
000.
please do yes so the the employees and
the other expenses you're forecasting
what it's going to be next time
but the transfer has that happened or is
that again a future transfer
again that's a future transfer so again
they're all forecasts of what we believe
will happen next financial year
cancer acme i think you had another
question
well i hear what catherine steele has
been saying and i have to say that i'm
less perplexed but not happy i don't i
still don't believe that we should be
comparing one budget to another budget
and while i understand that there might
be an underlying rationale in terms of
what we plan to do what we have been
doing and and what that view gives us to
what the next budget should be
i believe what we should be looking at
is we should be looking at the previous
barrage how we performed against it when
we should see that you know and then
then go on to the next budget
i'm sorry i don't find this very helpful
yeah i can i can understand that i mean
there's a couple of things that i'm i i
don't really understand i don't
understand why we're now putting into
into a
a budget
72 000 pounds to not use it but to
transfer it to reserves i don't
understand that uh that that seems
completely unnecessary to me
the other is
that
we're going to move quickly to income
coming to the council in 23 24
from the leisure center
but we don't we don't we're not told
that how much that might be
um it might be a very small amount we
don't know how it's going to be
calculated
um
and
i can i can recall a presentation some
years ago
in in respect of this
um
this con when we when
mid suffer we're looking at entering
into a contract the one that we've now
entered into
um we were to expect quite large sums of
income
but we've we appear to have made a
one-off payment of 175
to the company and no idea
how much money might come to the council
so
i you know i don't i don't know what to
do with that statement
so i can help because i have got some
additional information
one of the tables in your
report does show the years beyond 22-23
obviously 2223 is the budget that you
will be asked to approve at council in
february but we've shown the years
beyond that of what the numbers
currently look like for for information
at this stage um but i can say to you
that on that
leisure line
in 2324
we're anticipating 50 000 pounds income
back from from everyone active
uh the following year twenty four twenty
five uh anticipating seventy thousand
pounds and then twenty five twenty six
eighty five thousand pounds so it is
increasing over over that period of time
but getting nowhere near the figure that
we were told
three or four years ago to expect now
the world has changed since then i
appreciate that
just to clarify so the overall the the
figure that you're talking about um
you're absolutely right the total cost
of the the new lease over the 15-year
period was 1.5 million so what we've
done even through all of these
negotiations the total cost has never
changed we've just reprofiled it to try
and support what the cash flow situation
is with everyone active at that point so
what we've done in this
in this iteration which is the current
one that's going to go ahead is there's
a payment to everyone active but they'll
essentially pay back
1.75 million because of they've got to
pay that payment back to us plus the
overall contract still we get to the
council over a 15-year period 1.5
million so all we've done is reprofiled
it and you'll see we can get the exact
breakdown for you but towards the latter
years of the lease
the income back to the council
significantly increases to to cover that
so it's kind of profile towards the end
of the lease
thank you
um any any other questions from members
of the committee if that will turn to
council field
thank you
i hope you're
exercising your discretion and letting
me ask questions i i just wanted to
point out first of all that i too find
this 72k
very difficult to follow
it says reduce transfers to reserves of
72k and up on the table it says
transfers two reserves of 22k
of 72k sorry and it makes it it's just
not clear that is that meaning there's
some large sum of money
um which was transferred before and he's
now 72k less
or quite what and the the the
difference you know figures
in the uh in the text don't really
correlate you know without a lot of
mental arithmetic with the table which
makes it hard to follow
um so if i just say that
the real question perhaps lois is a
fairly small one it talks about
mid-suffolk making payments to claim
carbon reductions
does that mean there's a sum of money
that we are claiming from the government
for reducing carbon or does it must mean
that you know we've saved a couple of
kilos of carbon and we can claim that if
we paid
232 k so i i find that totally confusing
and also the point really that counts
rapping has been made that you would
expect a budget to be
to define what you're going to deliver
you know i am going to deliver
so many thousand
leisure activities or whatever it is i'm
going to deliver some
benefit and this is the cost
and the cost if you've changed the
delivery the cost may change but
one only is looking at
differential costs
smart questions figures but the the
question is one is what does anything
about carbon reductions mean and
maybe yet another go explaining the 72k
would be great
i'll
do the transfer to reserve uh question
but then i might ask my colleague to
come and come in on the other one in
terms of the carbon reductions
i think you were right in the second
half of your summary council of field
because you said
there is there is money coming from
reserve
to support the community's budget in the
current financial year so moving into
next year
there is a reduction
in the amount that's coming from reserve
which i think was what you were saying
so that's why it's zero
i don't know if it's entirely zero it
could well it could well be i'm not sure
there might be other elements within the
hot the overall budget that make it up
but there is
uh 72 000 pounds less
coming from reserve in
2223 compared to the current financial
year
and i'll hand over to my colleague from
sorry councillor councillor whitehead
just wanted to come in
perhaps
have it another way
more we'll talk about it perhaps the
more clear it'll be i mean my
understanding is in the current year
among the community's budget
there was like something like say a
pilot scheme that was tried out let's
say cost 72 000. because it was like a
pilot scheme we said we'll fund that
from reserve so we have some reserves so
although the cost was there the cost
came from reserve like rather than just
it in the current year
yeah so it's like a successful pilot if
it's then decided to continue it come to
in the future we say oh that worked
we'll include that as a base budget item
in future years this is just an example
so if you use it in future years as a
base budget item you've no longer got a
reserve to sort of subsidize it in other
words next year it actually hits hits
your um
bottom line if you like but from to a
better word is describing it
i hope that makes it clear
thank you
sure it was just on uh the carbon
reduction uh question or comment that
councillor field made so just to clarify
that there's two main reasons why the
council took on the account holdership
of the energy accounts one of those is
and i'll slightly caveat this that i'm
not the expert in this there are others
far more intelligently that can can
explain it better but we are in a
a situation as a council where you um
there's certain criteria to me to say
what um has to be counted in your
emissions and what you can say that you
have um
reduced so with our leisure centers we
have to count the carbon emissions from
those leisure centers in our baseline
which we have done
what we weren't allowed to do was show
that we'd made any benefits to that so
all of the works that have gone on at
the leisure centers with the heat pumps
and the
solar arrays we weren't allowed to say
that we'd done that and that had reduced
emissions by by however much it was
by taking on the energy account we are
allowed to say that we've done that we
still aren't allowed to say our baseline
has reduced interestingly but we are
allowed to say next to what our baseline
is that we have um reduced emitters at
those leisure centres by by x amount
it's a very complex formula
unfortunately
the second reason was that the public
sector decarbonisation scheme of which
across the two councils we got 1.4
million again we weren't allowed to even
bid for that if we weren't the energy
account holders so they were the two
main reasons that we took on and the
account holdership of the energy
accounts
um it occurs to me that if we're going
to go through a number of these slides
we're going to be here for a very long
time and what we're going to do from
during that time we're going to learn
a lot of detail
my concern is that
it's going to be difficult for us to
make recommendations on the detail
what we should be looking at i think is
how the how the budget has been
developed
and so that we can make
we can make recommendations at a more
strategic level
not
on the minutiae i have a couple of
thousand pounds or
a bit of carbon reduction here and there
so i don't know how you want to how you
want to pursue this shall we
shall we ask the officer to go through
the uh the rest of the slides fairly
quickly and then have a debate
about
what we can how we can add value i feel
we can't add value by changing a few
numbers on a few slides um
those numbers are
are
probably what are going to go forward
uh kazuraki young
thank you mr german uh with all due
respect i think
where we find ourselves is that we're
being presented with some extra
information perhaps not new information
but certainly extra information
and quite rightly uh councillors and the
com in the committee are seeking to
understand that information and and what
it means
pursuant to some of the questions that
have been asked
i do agree with you that we need to look
at this more strategically and i think
the fundamental issue with the
presentation of these budgets is the
opacity actually i mean it's not simple
and clear and i i think if we're going
to make a recommendation is is that this
should be a com complete fundamental
review of how we do these budgets and
present them to council
yeah i think yeah well we'll that will
be part of the debate
in a hopefully a little while time shall
we shall we proceed
with the presentation
um
and only ask questions if they're likely
to be
to be helpful in order to make a um a
recommendation could i just ask
a a question that
there will be an opportunity for all
members to ask the sorts of questions
that we've been asking i think this
these slides are going to are they going
to be presented to
to an all member briefing at some point
or to council
let's say there is an all member
briefing scheduled for mid mid-suffolk
on the 24th of january i believe it is
and i was sort of using
um the slides today to see if they were
going to be helpful as part of that all
member briefing so
um they could you know they could
definitely be included as part of that
suite
just conscious of the the length of the
you know the all member briefing but if
you feel that it would be useful to do
to run through this with all members i'm
more than happy to do that
how's the scarf
thank you i mean yes i i would agree i
mean had these been seen in advance we
wouldn't perhaps be asking necessarily
the questions that we're now asking
we've we've been sort of sidetracked up
an alley
which was what i referred to earlier
it's it alright
maybe it's not death by powerpoint but
i do find it really odd that we get
information at the very last minute and
it bamboozles councillors then into
we've got the information we've read the
papers we're looking at the strategic
direction of the budget there are
questions that we have on
um
is the budget secure in terms of some of
the figures that have been provided and
like council equing i think we should
concentrate on those
this is extremely useful information and
something that all members should know
but to bring it at this late stage i
think it's muddied the waters for uh the
scrutiny panel
i'm i'm wondering whether actually the
presentation
line by line for each directorate should
actually now go ahead because i think we
should be talking about the papers that
we're looking at and we've all seen in
advance rather than
confusing it with you know what's this
is useful information i think they
should come out perhaps at the all
member uh briefing and if the all member
briefing timing uh is not long enough
then increase the length of that
briefing then at least all members
will have seen this information before
it comes to council
and would have been able to ask some of
the detailed questions that we're now
getting and we're getting into my new
show rather than the strategic so i
think like counter equinox i would be
minded actually that we don't look at
the presentation as such in great detail
um perhaps the officers can just go
through it very very quickly and will
probably not likely to ask questions on
it today because i don't think it's
going to add to our
ability to make a decision on the budget
as presented within the papers thank you
is that does that have general agreement
among members i've seen nods
so we'll press on on that basis and
thank you catherine
thank you chad i was just perhaps going
to suggest that whether i do actually
continue and go through it because there
is quite a lot of information and i
think that probably will then take quite
a lot more of your meeting and say you
obviously have had the papers in advance
and have got questions on the paper
itself so i'm wondering whether perhaps
i circulate the slides to to all
counsellors even in advance of the all
member briefing and then all councillors
will have the chance to then come back
with any clarification questions as part
of that all member briefing on on the
24th of january
thank you catherine councillor you had
to
you had your hand right thank you mr
chairman actually i think catherine's
suggestion is a very good one right and
we should proceed on that basis
yeah we're all agreed on that
but thank you
so are there are there any more points
that either catherine or um
council whitehead would like to
make before
before we we ask questions about the
paper
or shall we go straight into questions
by counsellors
on the on the written report
were you intending to say anything of a
more general nature
i i wasn't chair i must have must admit
and so councillor whitehead's already
done his introduction so happy to open
it up to questions and and just
apologies that it didn't work for you
today we're trying something different
but we'll we'll learn from that and take
it forward thank you
um councillor scarf i think you had some
questions
thank you chair yes i did um page 12 of
our budget papers um
it refers to the annual increase in
staffing costs
uh of four percent
um
and uh
and how we came to that conclusion
um does this forecast in terms of the
staffing costs actually include the five
percent vacancy
management factor or is it based on a
full complement i.e is it based on a
percent staffing being in place or is it
based on the
vacancy management factor which is
uh further down on the paper which is
set at five percent that would be the
first question then there is a
supplementary on that perhaps
thank you
okay uh thank you councillor um
it's based on full staffing so um answer
that part of your question first so we
do budget for a full complement
but then after we've budgeted for the
full complement we make this adjustment
for that vacancy management so
the inflation for pay is based on the
full complement so we calculate it on on
the total budget
we've
based it on two percent for for next
year
that is
roughly what has been happening for the
last year or two and you'll see in the
report that we haven't yet reached
agreement nationally about the pay award
for the current financial year and the
main unions are currently balloting over
whether their members should take strike
action
the point where it reached if you like
the stalemate was a final offer of 1.75
had been made by by the employers so we
have yet to see if that position will
move
but based on sort of the level that the
discussions have been had at this year
and some previous years then we sort of
used the two percent figure as a as a
benchmark moving forward
thank you
thank you we're going going forward on
that with the vacancy management factor
at five percent and the report alludes
to the second quarter budget monitoring
port account cabinet which revealed that
we had a 17 vacancy rate um i appreciate
obviously we've done all we can in order
to recruit two vacant posts
um my comment was that 17 is is
obviously
rather high how realistic is the vacancy
management factor at five percent
because how can we make an analysis of
it because we've got the cabinet report
in september showing a 17 vacancy rate
but it doesn't give us the overall
figure thus far in the financial year i
mean what is the average overall vacancy
rate because i think it's very difficult
for us to quantify whether that vacancy
management factor is actually a
realistic figure at five percent
and i think that is a question i would
like some further clarification on thank
you
thank you councillor obviously the
figure in the cabinet report is a
snapshot in time so it was at that
particular point at the end of september
i believe the overall rate has been
running around about nine percent
somewhere around there for the current
financial year um but we have had a lot
of activity in terms of uh turnover and
recruitment and i know there is an awful
lot of recruitment activity happening at
the moment to try and fill the vacancies
that we have
so
we didn't want to increase the vacancy
factor because we obviously want to get
the staff in post to deliver everything
that we need we need to deliver for our
for our communities so we felt it was
right to leave it at the
i suppose the more normal i think kovid
has certainly had an impact on our
vacancy factor
because back in 2020 certainly during
the first lockdown
we were unable to recruit for quite a
period of time we've subsequently
learned how to do that through
subsequent lockdowns and have adapted
all our processes but i think we are
still in a slight position of catch up
in terms of recruiting through to all of
those vacancies that in essence got
frozen during the lockdown in in 2020 so
i hope that sort of gives you some
further information
sorry i might as well keep going
yeah okay um yeah i mean the nine
percent is a useful figure to know
because
you say the snapshot in time is 17 and
the vacancy management factor at five
percent we've got no idea what it was
overall throughout the year and i think
that nine percent would have been
helpful to be in the papers because it
is an area of concern for members as to
whether we can deliver the services that
we're expected to deliver as a council
if we don't have the staff to deliver
those services um
if i go on then um on page 16 under
paragraph 4.4
uh
six
um
[Music]
it talks about the corporate program of
work which will be developed early in
this year to enable some broad-based
numbers to put against a two to three
year program
for savings because recognizing that we
still have to make efficiencies drive
down costs and cut out work that does
not add value
this uh i mean my experience another
council is this is called like a
transformation program
if um
built into the base budget from next
year which i would expect that
transformation program would be there is
obviously a risk that the savings will
not materialize to their full effect for
example
the transformation program at the county
council hasn't delivered on
expectations in the current financial
year and there's a carry forward to next
year but in order to set a balanced
budget we're now um
assuming that just over nine million
pounds of transformation program
undelivered is going to now be delivered
to set that balanced budget so there is
a there is a risk there
and
i wonder quite what is the
right way
uh for the council to move forward with
this program because i think if we're
going to make these cost savings we
ought to identify what they are and then
we ought to be able to measure as to
whether they've been delivered and what
would be the right vehicle in terms of
council committee would it be overview
and scrutiny would it be cabinet would
it be ordinary governance
in order to monitor that work because i
think
those kinds of issues are things that
the scrutiny committee may
well
be able to
assist with doing the financial year i.e
ongoing budget monitoring
but in particular if there's a
transformation program or if it's called
something like that
it's something we could get to grips
with it's figures and we can monitor it
and see whether
it's actually delivering against what
the officers have
said so i just wonder
what is the view of offices in terms of
that going forward
so point points very well made and i
think
the reason we haven't included anything
in the budget at the moment is because
we didn't want to commit before we'd
actually done the work to assess
what is the likely level of savings so
that's why there isn't anything included
in the budget at this point in time
but yes i think i would uh agree with
you that this perhaps could be once that
that program is put together it could be
a useful role for overview and scrutiny
to to monitor that
um
the program itself will say hasn't
actually been developed yet but once
once it has that does feel like a a
reasonable role in terms of the
committee to look at that in the future
thank you mr chairman uh really it's a
follow-up to councillor scarce
question really
um
and i think he makes a very valid point
however i'm a bit curious as to
what's going on with this particular
line item of the budget because
while this is not being included in it i
notice that if we look at the figures
the budget for that
is going going to dub more than double
in the next financial year and it's
going to double and continue at that
rate in in future financial years so
what are we spending that money on
and what's that what are we going to get
for it
and if i could add to that um please
because i think
my question is
partly similar to to that question and
uh and that's that's around the uh
cabinet paper that um set out the the
outcomes for the
the following years and
do we do we have the resources do we
have the staff
do we have the finance in order to
to meet the outcomes that are being
developed
and the action points have been
developed from
from the corporate plan because it it
what what was presented
um
just just this week earlier this week
was
pretty far far reaching um
and
i would have said pretty expensive
um
and yet you know have have we got
built into this budget
enough finance and enough staff to
actually carry out the work that's
needed to meet those outcomes
thank you they're two nicely linked
questions so that that's useful to have
those together because i think one does
answer the other
because what we are suggesting is that
we do need more resource in this area
it's an area that the council has i
think underinvested in you're right the
council has just agreed the new outcomes
framework and we don't have the resource
uh centrally within the organization at
the moment to monitor that and report on
it to you to yourselves as councillors
and make sure that we are delivering
against you know the programmes of work
um there are other areas that are also
being developed as part of that i mean
we were just talking a minute ago about
that
programme of driving out efficiencies
now this particular team and i'm
assuming that uh cancer eq pin young was
talking about the the strategic policy
performance and insight team
this team would also be the focus for
driving that work across the
organisation as well so we know we need
resource to be able to take that program
forward as well
we've also been lacking in terms of the
the policy work that we do across the
organization so
all the raft of initiatives that the
government issues having a central point
where they can be gathered
analyzed
work out what is the impact going to be
on the council and how do we need to to
respond to that would also form part of
of this team
and and data work as well we have an
awful lot of data but trying to convert
that into
um useful intelligence that we can then
use to make decisions on so there's
quite a few areas that this new team
but part of this new team is also moving
resources from another area within the
organization so it's not all brand new
we're consolidating where we've got some
resources in in another part of the the
organization at the moment which is the
law and governance team
bringing that together with what is
already in this particular area but then
supplementing it as well
because we know we need more resource in
in this particular area so it's over a
combination of
extra
i suppose outputs that you will see an
outcomes from this particular area of
work
plus moving resources that we've already
got within the organization and just
consolidating it and making sure that it
it's all um joined up for the future
does that answer your question counts
right for you
you look rather skeptical mr sherman
there was a lot of information there
yeah but i think it does actually go a
long way to arts towards answering my
question but it does beg another
question in fact
which is more generic to the whole
budget and and the staffing
because it relates to councillor scarf's
point about vacancy rates and and
clearly while
we can attribute some difficulties to
the kobe pandemic situation i just
wondered to what extent
given the discussions that they've been
going on about the ability to recruit to
this council and we have been losing
quite a lot of staff to what extent are
we taking account of that in terms of
the the salaries and the compensation
packages that we're going to pay people
to come and work here
council white's head
yeah i hope i can add to this debate
rather than detract from it but the um
these are sort of questions really that
this is what opium scrutiny and budget
should really be looking at questions
like the vacancy rate and the
deliverability et cetera
and i just want to make the point that
um
we just have something called the
transformation fund
and that over the years you know we've
sort of met merged two workforces moved
out of needham and hadley and came to
here i mean that really was
transformation you know a big word
um
took the decision to change the
transformation fund to call it the
growth and efficiency fund and basically
i mean the sort of the that was sort of
created from growth and efficiencies and
it was used to drive further growth
efficiencies it just seems to me that
we're almost post transformation now
we're sort of more like fine tuning
without sort of denigrating you know
future things not standing on our
laurels but um that's really i just feel
that transformation perhaps is
an outdated word but um
just above that table just above that
paragraph
4.466 um
the table shows that we're forecasting
surpluses of about three and a half
million um year on year going forward so
i think there's an awful lot of um
resource there when people say is it are
the finances there to do future
transformations to achieve the
very high level of um
aspirations and objectives that we've
set ourselves
so i think from that point of view and
just going back to the vacancy
assumption i think the the higher the
vacancy assumption you build in the less
prudent the budget is and we have to
hope and anticipate that we can
fill these vacancies and get the council
moving forward and achieving our
aspirations
yeah thank you thank you for that but
you referred to the three and a half
million that we don't spend each year
um is it is it prudent
to have this money in reserves or would
it be better for our residents
if we actually
spent it on things that they need
this is this is for many years been one
of my concerns that we
you know we
we we tell ourselves or you tell us that
we're very prudent
um
but i feel that we would be more prudent
if we actually
um provided services for our residents
and that would need staff
so if you're addressing that question
direct to myself i mean we we have put
those four
lots of one million pounds plus the
other million from the climate change i
mean these are pretty ambitious
um
i mean we're just fortunate to have that
flexibility that um
you know i think virtually
every day i see in sort of local
government announcements where i think
it was yesterday bristol city was
looking for 19 million pounds of cuts to
make i think we're pretty unique in
having these surpluses but we you know
we do as you say we do need to then
decide what to do with it what we can
realistically do with it
and you know any suggestions that come
out to every scrutiny i'm sure will be
very much
encouraged by the cabinet and debated by
the cabinet
yeah thank you for that i mean i would
say that what you've done is to move
four million pounds from one jam jar and
put it in four separate jam jars but but
uh
i i i don't think i don't think you're
identifying what services you're going
to provide you're identifying what it
might might be spent on it um i in the
rainy season but i think we're in the
rainy season but i've got to be careful
not to not to stray on to political
points but my overall my overall point
is i feel we should be looking to
provide services not looking
to
save money
council scarf
uh thank you chair
page 23 appendix b
um
gives us the general fund capital budget
um my question uh is concerning
carryforwards from the 21 to 22 year
into uh next year
i'm not going to ask you a question on
investment in commercial delivery but i
am going to ask you a question regarding
the housing related items um there are
four items there where there's a quite
significant carry forward of half a
million pounds
from those four uh key areas of the
housing section
i don't know whether this is a question
for uh our assistant director of housing
or whether it's for catherine or uh
councillor whitehead the portfolio
holder hal
um
how are you going to ensure that those
significant carry forwards are actually
spent
in this next coming financial year
because it's been an area of concern
to members for some years in particular
the mandatory disabled facilities grant
um
carry forward is quite considerable
and i appreciate that that is improving
but how are we going to ensure that
those carry forwards are actually spent
in the forthcoming budget year because
we're clearly not delivering against
those uh budgets because we've got those
carry boards and it's not the first time
that we've had carry boards on those so
how robust
do you think our
council is in enabling those monies to
actually be spent because
there's a huge
need for um
disabled facilities grants and i accept
that we've done a huge amount of work on
that in in in the year since i've joined
the council in order to ensure that we
actually do meet residents priorities
but i'm still concerned that there's
significant carry forwards
so i think that's a question i'd like
answer please i'm not sure by who
gavin's indicated he would be prepared
to answer that question
thank you chair and uh thank you
councillor scarf for the the question
you're correct um fundamentally you're
correct in terms of
there's been huge improvements in
relation to uh the mandatory disabled
facilities grants as a result of the
introduction of the independent living
service both in baby and mid-suffolk and
uh councils across
uh suffolk which has been in place now
uh approximately a year um scrutiny of
that performance not just baby mid
suffix but but suffolk as a whole is
taking place through the suffolk housing
board for which i sit as along with
heads of housing and and colleagues from
the county um in terms of scrutinizing
that performance and scrutinizing the
ability to to spend those grants what
i'm pleased to say is that
mid-suffolk actually lead by example in
in regards to the expenditure over the
past year
and actually for this year's budget um
that we are reaching a a climax and
conclusion to we will have actually
spent the the year's budget
inve invariably what we face is a
situation particularly with that grant
that there has been an underspend year
on year for a number of years and it
will take us a period of time to play
catch up
i think what you'll see with that budget
over the next 12 18 24 months is
actually
um
the likelihood that we'll move from
surpluses and reserves to a position
where actually we fundamentally have to
ask the question who do we provide a
disabled facilities grant to and who
don't we provide a disabled facilities
grant to because actually
if we continue the same trajectory as we
are
we'll actually spend the budget and want
to spend more
invariably in terms of disabled
facilities grants that is uh apportioned
to us through the better care funds that
uh the county council receives um and we
have faced the situation particularly
over the last 12 18 months where
additional monies have been granted to
us by the government in year beyond what
was set um at the start of any financial
year
but please rest assured that based on
the performance
we are we are looking uh to reduce that
that reserve
and spend that as soon as practicable um
and as such and it plays into
conversations you've had about staffing
this morning um one of the areas was to
to upskill
and and
pump prime our service and i'm pleased
to say in terms of the private sector
housing team
um in recent weeks and months we've
appointed an independent living service
manager uh to work with ots that we are
now funding and and colleagues to to
conduct that work and what we are doing
is continuing to find new ways in which
we can promote that money and spend that
money so working with hospitals hospital
discharge working with doctors surgeries
working with charitable organizations
that possibly uh have have scope and not
just about physical um also looking at
other disabilities as well
in regards to just the some of the
renovation
and then the homes grants
again uh we've been through a
fundamental review of that team um over
the past 12 months and i'm pleased to
say in the latter half of of last year
we've been able to recruit to a number
of of roles and and as such as an
example of that
is an empty homes officer
to take forward that work which we
haven't actually had in in historic
times we've had a very small private
sector housing team
but not with with individual roles and
responsibilities
and as such this week we were looking at
a draft version of empty homes policy to
bring forward to cabinet um in the next
couple of months and and actually that
will be the first time we've had an
empty homes policy since 2013 as a
council so
hopefully that gives you uh reassurance
that actually fundamental work is being
done in the background in order for us
to be able to spend these moneys
students
i'd just like to thank the assistant
director for his very clear
explanation uh and uh i wish them well
with their work i was aware that the
work was going on so i'm particularly
pleased but it might point to
in future perhaps where we actually
spend some of the council's monies
because i think
trying to keep people in their own homes
without moving them on to especially
you know
to
care situation is going to be a real
issue in the coming years for not only
the county council but all of the
district and borough councils
thank you uh councillor carsten
thank you very much mr chairman um four
point three three the non-pay inflation
um
it says the non-pay inflation's being
calculated at two percent
is that up to date enough considering
the um
the level of inflation in october and
november this year
and um could you
tell me a bit about the um thought
process behind the managers
um cutting the cloth to
fit
um
and to deal with that um inflation
rather than an actual real terms
increase in their budgets
thank you councillor
um yes in terms of the non-pay inflation
the the two percent relates to 23 24 and
onwards
so for 22 23 as you say people have been
asked to cut their cut the cloth and
i'll come back to that in in a moment
um
two percent is what we've built in at
the moment i know the government is uh
hoping that the current high level of
inflation will drop back
and they're sort of saying somewhere
between 23 and 24 it might drop back to
their target level of of two percent so
at the moment we've gone with that two
percent say for the year 23 24 we've got
obviously higher than that at this
current point in time
but that is um
i suppose an estimation at the moment as
to what's going to happen that far into
the future and then this time next year
when you're looking at your 23 24 budget
then we will obviously revise
those assumptions but it's just our
working assumption at the moment for for
that far in advance
based on what you know the government is
indicating might happen in terms of
inflation rates
and in terms of cutting the cloth
i think i've set out in the report that
i've asked managers to take a slightly
different approach to
how they put their budgets together this
year
because reflecting on the fact that both
councils have historically underspent
their budgets over the last the last few
years
so i was reflecting on the fact that i
think all of the managers tend to be
quite prudent in their own individual
service areas
and then when we amalgamate that across
the whole organization
then not all of that uh prudency is
gonna is gonna come to bear you know so
some not everything comes out and
perhaps what they're thinking might be
worst case so i have asked managers to
to try and be a bit more realistic with
their assumptions this year and part of
that was to ask them to see if they
could absorb the inflation during 2223
i think most service areas have actually
managed to achieve that one or two small
exceptions where they where they haven't
been able to
and i appreciate you know it's probably
quite a stretch for for this coming
financial year because of where
inflation is at the moment
but that's just sort of the rationale
behind behind the approach or a slightly
different approach for this year
thank you did you have a follow-up
question
no i think that does explain it i i do
um worry about these overspends but i
understand that they are a result of um
budgeting for the worst case scenario
and um not that things haven't money
hasn't been spent and things haven't
been achieved so yeah now i'm quite
happy with that explanation thank you
thank you very much councilman
um yeah my question was also relating to
appendix b
environment and projects replacement
refuge freighters i see we're looking to
put forward 2.2 million in 22-23
is this likely to cover the cost of
replacing all the freighters in that
year because i notice in the following
year you perhaps look at 188 000 which
is obviously
quite a small small amount could you
clarify that position for me please
i believe the 2.2 million i said council
of foaming's just put a hand up i
believe the 2.2 million is the majority
of the fleet but they don't always all
get replaced at exactly the same point
in time i think there are some that are
on a slightly different schedule we do
replace them every seven years and
they're saying i think the majority do
happen to fall in in a particular year
but there are some i think that are on a
slightly different replacement schedule
so hence why you see some in different
years but i'll
i'll let councillor fleming come in if
she's got more information than i have
um through the chair thank you i assume
um it's all right if i just say
something briefly on this point
the investment that's set aside for for
new freighters
and there is some uncertainty associated
with that due to the um fact that we're
all waiting on the environment bill
details of what these waste freighters
will will exactly
need how they will be designed to meet
the
needs of the new
waste collection policy and we expect
that
food waste and possibly glass
will need curbside collection
and that being the case the freighters
will need obviously to be very different
to the ones we have now how we don't
know yet what this what exactly how
these freighters do need to be designed
the suffolk waste partnership which i
sit on representing mid-suffolk the
approach being taken in suffolk
is to try to
maybe get our existing freighters to
last a bit longer
before replacing them and then finding
that they're unsuitable for um for the
job they need to do so i just wanted to
point that out
thank you chair
thank you are there any other questions
cancer activity
well thank you mr chairman um as a
follow-up to council miller's question
really if we
are planning to spend 2.2 million on on
new freighters
they're designed and ready i mean you
know they're not going to suddenly
design a whole new load of new
freighters because the policies changed
i mean you can't
i mean it takes a while to design and
build a vehicle i'm a bit puzzled by
councillor fleming's response because
either the vehicles are going to be
available to be purchased in the in the
financial year or they're not
perhaps there are different designs of
freighter
would you like to respond to councillor
fleming to that that question or that
point
um
i will as best i can this is a question
of great concern actually to most local
authorities in the in england
because while the existing design of
freighters here
is um
is pretty simple
the whole the structure that goes on the
back of the lorry will need to be
replaced in order to accommodate food
waste
in particular and glass separately
there is some question about whether
the glass and food waste traitors will
be different to the ones that pick up
the um other recycling there are
questions about how the um
murph at blakenham will need to be
redesigned to accommodate this the
investment involved is going to be very
large now the government has said
that
it should be cost neutral to local
authorities
so um that is the assumption we're all
going on at the moment even though we
may um in reality doubt that
thank you acosta casting you had a
question i i was just going to um
comment on that i was going to say we've
got to be quite careful that we don't
get design mixed up with specification
when we're talking about phrases but
it's also important that we have money
put aside because um
even if the government does
finance these freighters there's
probably a lot of opportunities to make
them better than the um
than the base
freighter that the government wants like
obviously weight and things like that
are massively important when you're
running hvo fuel and um it's it's good
to have this money put aside just to um
just to look at
cost savings and improvements in those
actual freighters beyond what we're
asked to do
thank you
counselor muller you've got a question
okay yeah um thank you sam if you're
you're your answer to that um when i
lived in northampton i lived in left
northampton in 2010 we actually used to
have um the glass collected
um at that stage so there must be
vehicles available
because if they're using them sort of 12
years ago there must be some of these
these vehicles must still be available
so that'll just be the comment that i
was going to make thank you
yeah i mean i believe that there are
electric vehicles available there are a
whole range of different specifications
for what goes on at the back of the the
vehicle um and yeah we have relatives in
northampton and i think they have moved
on from from then um
but we
no doubt will be driven by
by the environment bill
um if we haven't got any more questions
can we move on to debate
before that council appeal do you have
any questions
not at the moment i don't think they'll
have a number of small ones but the
strategic ones
are limited
thank you so we will move on to debate
and if we can
um
start to formulate any recommendation
that we might make
on the budget that would be helpful
we've made a lot of comments and i'm
sure that officers and the portfolio
holder will take account of the comments
that we've made
but do we have any general
recommendations that we might want to
put well either general recommendations
or specific recommendations
on this year's budget
no oh councillor scarf thank you so much
starting off the debate well joe i think
it's actually very difficult for us to
make a recommendation on on the budget
we've asked
i'm pleased in the latter stage of the
meeting that we've gone to strategic
questioning of the budget and uh i thank
other councillors for their
contributions on that because i think
that is really what we're here today to
do
in terms of making a recommendation
where we might um
consider altering the budget based on
what's in front of us i think it's
somewhat difficult
perhaps the scrutiny committee should
know the budget uh and and uh ask
cabinet to take on board the comments
that we've made because
i don't know
a specific recommendation i think i find
would be hard
to deliver one of the recommendations i
would make is that we do actually
drastically review i know we've tried to
do it in a different way this year but
it clearly didn't work
to start off with so i think
one of the recommendations i would make
is if if we're going to be presented
with information we must be presented
with that in sufficient time for us to
actually take that into our
considerations even if it's only
background information as to how you got
from this year's budget to next year's
budget and what the changes are
because i think
to present them at the meeting as we
found today
has just confused members to to too much
so i think that's one of the
recommendations i would like uh to make
from the overview and scrutiny committee
that we
take a serious look at how we look as a
committee at the budget how potential
for
monitoring the budget including um and
i'll use the word transformation uh
including how the transformational
changes that we're about to
look at in terms of the budget are
monitored
in you know how it how is the budget
developed across the mid-southwest
during the year i think you know there's
some work to do there so
i think
that certainly for me would be the
outcome of today's
meeting
i think it's very valid that you raise
the question about
reviewing the development of the budget
throughout the year
we've got to be very careful that we are
scrutinizing the development of a new
budget not monitoring the details
of the current year's expenditure
but if if you would like to put together
some wording around
um
a
a a a strategic review of the
development of the budget
throughout the year i think that's
that's something which
i would find helpful i think would be a
step forward and i think
it is something which other councils
already do
and it is recommended
um also
by professionals that we should do that
so
uh cancer scarf okay well i'll i'll come
back then chair and and move a motion
then
if it would be helpful um i'll move the
following motion that the overview and
scrutiny committee looked strategically
at the developing budget for mid-south
district council throughout
the
coming year and on year
and develop a develop a way of
monitoring
how that budget development is
progressing
bit bit wordy but perhaps the officers
can help us with clarify that perhaps
yes
we can make something from that it's got
a quite a few developments in there and
developing but yes i mean basically we
want we want to see it
as it is
being put together rather than
when it's too late to change anything
other than one or two small sums of
money within it we want to we want to
see the basic assumptions that are being
made
as they are being made not after they've
been incorporated into the build-up of
the budget so i think that's that's the
basis i think of of what you're saying
um so we'll we'll attempt to put that
into a form of words so we'll note the
budget
ask
the cabinet member and officers to take
account of the comments that were being
made
and we will
will seek to find a way to
um
uh review
a developing budget throughout the year
um and the
the sort of the strategic
the strategic
decisions and recommendations as they as
they're built into the budget
something along those lines
emily are you happy that you can make a
form of words out of that
sure i'm happy to to offer a suggestion
if um that's helpful
at this stage um
so i've been furiously scribbling um
committee members and and largely um
used the majority of councillor scarf's
words
but also picking up your earlier
comments around the responsibility for
budget scrutiny and financial monitoring
as an as an ongoing concern throughout
the year
so i think the recommendation
may be suitable along the lines of that
that the overview and scrutiny committee
is involved in the scrutiny of the
budget as it is developed
to enable earlier scrutiny
and at the process and that the ongoing
process of financial monitoring by
councillors is reviewed
to better distribute the
responsibilities between the cabinet and
the various scrutiny committees
yeah we don't we don't want to monitor
the expenditure we just want to monitor
the development of the budget
and assumptions made in developing i
think
because right beyond
but i do think that we need to
understand that
how we're spending the money and are we
spending the money on the priorities
that were agreed and if we haven't spent
it on those priorities you know what are
we going to do about it
so i think there is a
a question about the the the budget
process and and how
um
we can seek to improve that process
i absolutely agree but what we don't
want to do
is do half of the work that audio will
be carrying out um
and other work that cabinet do that
we we have a site of
and the
performance man there's so there's so
much data out there different people
looking at it but we need to take a
strategic view of the data how it's
being used and how the how the budget
for the following year
is being developed
do you need a secondary thought
counselor scarf's motion i think i think
we do if so i'm happy to second it
right
so that being the case
yeah
so that being the case we've reached a
consensus on what needs to go into the
um the recommendation back to
um to to council to officers to
implement and to the cabinet member can
we take a break of say five minutes
whilst the governance officer
and um
and the monitoring officer put together
a
um a form of words that we might be more
we might be happy then to to vote upon
council why i said if you made jeff
would you make an observation in terms
of you know how the budget develops i
mean even as the cabinet member for
finance they don't sit on or sit in and
observe the uh senior leadersh
leadership team uh you know in terms of
how that when they're pulling the budget
together i'm not looking over their
shoulder as such even as a cabinet
member basically as a cabinet we give
them the direction in terms of our
outcomes and what we want to achieve and
then we say to the officers this is what
we want to achieve next year now go away
and
have a delivery plan and that delivery
plan then creates a budget i just i'm
just a big
concern that you're almost asking to to
to be more involved in the process than
even myself as as a government for
finance so i say we sort of set the
set what's needed and then
then when it comes back we sort of
forensically look at it
yeah i think
yes i understand i understand your role
in it and we don't want to take your
role uh but what we what we do need to
to know is how it's being developed what
the assumptions are
um and
and not to be
not to have a load of detail thrown at
us at the last minute
um
and
we we need to see the strategic
information
as the budget is being developed we
don't we don't need to we don't need to
know
the details the my new show of what the
what the plans are
for spending the money on specific items
but we do need to know
and scrutinize
the
the the the sort of basic information
that's going into the development of the
budget
is that right
because repre
uh have i
i roughly summarize what we need to see
or do you have something else to add
um
i'm not entirely sure i've understood
what you've just said to be honest um i
i do
agree we don't need to delve into the
ministry of the budget but i do think we
do need one to look at how
the process could be improved if it
could be improved
um because clearly from some of the
comments and questioning earlier on in
this meeting
we as the overview and scrutiny
committee are not satisfied with the
process um so i think whatever
recommendation
we make needs to take account of the
fact that we want that reviewed
and to review the process of the budget
development yeah
yeah we can put that those words in
there yes
okay
well i then suggest that we take a
five-minute break five or six minutes
break
and and come back
and then we have to look at
what the officers have come up with as a
form of words
thank you we're back in the meeting now
we've had a break
and the governance officer is about to
read out the recommendation that's been
drafted whilst we've had the break based
on
the comments that were made
and the motions from various members
so if we could listen to the governance
officer that would be great please
thank you chair the recommendations are
that the overview and scrutiny committee
notes that the general fund budget
2022 to 23 and four-year outlook and ask
that the cabinet of the cabinet member
for finance and officers take into
consideration the comments made at the
meeting
and that the budget preparation process
is reviewed by the section 151 officer
and the monitoring officer to ensure
that the overview and scrutiny committee
can be involved earlier in the
development of the budget enabling a
more strategic approach to scrutinizing
the budget further the
monitoring officer and constitution
working group reviews the terms of
reference for the ovu and secretary
committee and the joint audit and
standards committee to ensure that
financial security scrutiny is being
undertaken in the most appropriate way
and
our general intent uh a lot a lot
sharper so yeah i think that that gives
us a number of ways of looking at the
way that the budget
is developed here in the year i think
that's a very sensible approach so i'll
be happy to move that
thank you and council mansell you still
continue to say i'm happy
thank you well that the wording will be
in the electronic voting
and vote is now in progress
thank you chad that's six votes four so
that's unanimous thank you very much
so we now move on to the next item
we're on to item seven
which is
the hra account
an hra budget
and
uh catherine are you going to introduce
this report or is gavin or
right thank you okay
councillor whitehead thank you um thank
you chair um
as i already explained in my
introduction to the general fund budget
we've streamlined the
process budget setting this year
so this is the opportunity to challenge
the assumptions and look at the risks
involved
i'm pleased to hear that we don't have a
powerpoint uh presentation toolbox for
this because that housing revenue
account is very much a single department
a ring fenced account so hopefully all
the detail is already within the report
before you
so the report highlights the effects
that kerbin 19 has had on the hra and
its finances
rank collection has barely been affected
any shortfalls can and will be collected
over the extended period
due to the nature of the long-term
secure tendencies so that's good news
but on the other hand the pandemic
significantly significantly impacted the
new bill's schedule
has led to both material supply issues
and significant cost increases in
materials
the pandemic also led to a backlog of
repairs and maintenance work during
lockdown which has significantly
impacted expenditure in this current
year
leading to a predicted 747 000 deficit
for this current year
the impact from this backlog will
continue into the 22-23 financial year
officers from the housing team working
with the finance team
have taken a forensic look at the
expenses we have incurred in the
building services over recent years
to ensure we have realistic expense
figures in our 2223 budget
the current year's budget for this area
which was
3.629 million has been increased to
4.148 million for 22.23
now i suspect that one of the first
things that will have drawn
members attention when first reading
this report was the proposed council
house rent increases
certainly mine
using the government approved formula of
cpi plus 1
will lead to a rent increase of 4.1
percent from the first of april 22.
now that equates to an average rent
increase of 3 pounds 34 per week
the rent increase generates additional
revenue of 601 000 for the hra
so despite all the cost pressures which
i've just previously referred
the hra budget for next year is coming
out just above a break-even position
now in contrast to general fund position
our hra cannot objectively be said to be
an entirely healthy position
total reserves are just under three
million which might sound substantial
but in fact work out at less than one
thousand pound per property
with all the challenges ahead arising
from our carbon neutral aspirations and
the improvements that will be needed to
energy efficiency of our dwelling stock
it's vital we have a robust hra account
going forward
and current reserves alone certainly
won't meet those aspirations
and it's for that reason really we set
out in paragraph 416 two tables which
show the impact of these rent increases
on the hra over various extensive
periods of time and to illustrate the
vital contributions they make to the hra
finances
i'm happy to answer any questions that
members may have and the finance team
together with gavin fisk
a.d for housing are here to assist me
so hopefully between us we can provide
further information and commentary to
assist your overview and scrutiny
of this budget thank you chairman
thank you councilman whitehead
do i have
somebody wishing to ask the first
question please
no questions uh counter casting thank
you
thank you
um
the right to buy um
in mid suffolk is down um
from what the original projections
were from um projector 20
um
and actually sold 12. i think that's the
same as
very similar to last year's projections
down
from
lower than the projections um
how are we
working out those um projections for
right to buy
please
oh
gavin well obviously this is crystal
ball gazing but uh and as far as we're
trying to make a science out of um
of this i'll ask um gavin to just
perhaps go through
a process
thank you uh for the question uh
councillor casten in terms of right to
buy there there obviously is um uh
a difficulty uh in in looking at and
monitoring the markets in terms of of
sales what we saw
naturally during covid was a decline but
we have seen that that steadily rise
again what we are able to do is
obviously look across uh both a short
and a longer period of time so um in
terms of um any period uh accounts or or
the department
of leverage communities and housing
would look at a period over 10 years and
we can look at and see consistent trends
in terms of the the numbers yes there
will naturally be small peaks and
troughs um but but on average uh we set
we sell between 15 and 20 um in in in a
normal given year putting aside
covid
our hra business plan has an indicative
number in there
and as part of the work that we're doing
both now but but also continuously we're
always looking to to revise that because
clearly
if we were to underestimate the number
of houses
sold it would have an impact on on
rental income
so we are adjusting the level
continuously depending on on what we see
and actually i think we can see going
forward that we're going to sort of meet
that that original projection of of 20
uh over the next uh 12 18 months
thank you
are there no other questions uh council
mansell
thank you um maybe i'm i haven't read it
the paper properly but
um the that paragraph under 4.16
about the dwelling rents does that take
into consideration
um our
new properties um and the rents will be
getting from those rise to only existing
numbers because you talk about
effectively
30 affordable rent properties but that's
a reduction of 30 social housing
properties but what about the new ones
are they incorporated into that table
thank you councilman for the question
just check check in with colleagues and
and perhaps just introduce jenny
smithy's as uh our hra business partner
now so she's sort of more involved in
the detailed work um we haven't included
an assumption for any new build because
we're not sure exactly when during the
year they would come on stream so i
suppose we've taken the slightly
cautious approach of waiting for them to
actually be built and then we will build
that into the following year's budget
thank you um counselor scarf
um thank you chair well similar question
uh as to what i asked in the last
session on the general fund um
on page 30 uh paragraph 4.21 we've got
the planned maintenance carryforward of
one and a half million pounds which is
obviously a significant sum of money
which put together with the budget for
this year
gives us a total spend of 6.485
million as you can see from the figures
forecasting forward
that's a very heavy sum and i'm pleased
to see that that sum is in there
how realistic is it that we will be able
to spend that money in this forthcoming
financial year
um because clearly planned maintenance
helps to
potentially reduce also the repairs
budget which obviously we're increasing
uh by half a million this year when if
you give us some details on that please
thank you gavin
thank you chair um thank you council
scarf for the question um i think
fundamentally what we've seen in in
recent years is carry forwards in in
regards to
particularly the planned maintenance
budget and and more often or not the the
capital program for new build as well
specifically in relation to the plans
main sense fully correct um and support
and echo your um your commentary that if
we have an effective plan maintenance
schedule it should both a reduce the
number of jobbing repairs or day-to-day
repairs um and provide uh housing that
is of a of a standard and quality that
that we would all expect
um in terms of the uh carry forward some
of the things that we are doing to
ensure that we spend
those receipts we are looking at
staffing resource and bringing in uh
additional resource where appropriate in
in terms of
what we need to complement the team
we're also looking at the use of
procurement frameworks and we've had an
individual in recent times over that the
first half of of this current financial
year
solely focused on contracts so
there is a little bit of a legacy issue
here so if i go back to you'll recall
the um the development of or the
investigation of
a joint venture
that we were looking at previously as
part of that development we naturally
stopped or took stock of which contracts
we had coming up for renewal because
traditionally we'll have a kitchen and
bathroom refurbishment contract with a
said contractor for perhaps four or five
years we naturally took the opportunity
because what we didn't know was if the
joint venture business case came off and
if it was approved actually what we'd be
wanting to put into that joint venture
to both benefit the joint venture and
benefit us
so as a part of that we have got a
legacy that we've got a number of
contracts that have come to a stop and
what we've been doing over the last 18
months or two years is is letting small
contracts uh for smaller values for a
short period of time the work that we've
been doing over this year is to let
longer contracts for a longer period of
time so that we can increase the supply
and throughput of of those works and
that continues and one thing that we've
also been trying to do is use
procurement frameworks rather than have
to use alternative procurement and
rendering mechanisms which
at some times can can generate uh speeds
uh into in terms of them already being
approved
and lastly i'd point to some really big
ticket items so um moving towards epcc
of all of our homes by 2030 an ambitious
program to retrofit and and make
improvements to our stock and and some
some big ticket items
we've got some big schemes where we want
to invest significantly hearthstone
corner is is an example of that in terms
of an exemplar scheme that is going to
consume and absorb um significant
amounts of that plan makes schedule so
as i sit here today we've got a plan to
to to drive that that budget and spend
and exhaust those budgets
um
can i then ask a question about well
it's not specifically about palestine
corner but you
a significant part of that was it six
six point four eight five million
uh
are you saying that a significant part
of that is tied up in schemes like
houston corner and
coming up with an exemplar scheme now
let's assume that that is successful
will there not then need to be in future
years
a similar
big increase in spend because you're
going to get
bit what you call big ticket items
across the whole of the district
yeah if i can come back um to your
question chair so
houston corner is in is an example of a
project where we're looking at an
exemplar scheme and we're actually
looking at doing something quite radical
with the number of units there
and spending um in excess of uh the
typical expenditure that we would expect
to spend per property
over the lifespan of that property
the work that we've been doing and will
come forward through the hra business
plan um as council white had described
um is actually looking at our overall
stock profile yes it's natural to look
at smaller schemes as and when they
present themselves maybe high
vacancy rates might mean that we want to
do something slightly different in that
area or that location or we have
properties of a certain type
and certain traits which allow us or
want us to makes us to do something
different in regards to the work that
we've been doing we've been working with
the energy saving trust over this year
to evaluate each and every single one of
our properties across baby suffolk based
on 88 different environmental measures
and what that can provide us and what it
has provided us with is actually
a real baseline of every single property
and the level of works that we need to
spend to get that property to an epcc or
beyond that then to to to to to a higher
level
and as as such what we will do when we
invariably do every day is evaluate our
stock there are going to be some
properties that will never ever reach
our expectations in terms of an epcc
just because of their construction or
their design or their location and so
actually what we'll need to do is be
flight foot and and more flexible in our
approach in terms of looking at
acquisitions but also disposals also
redevelopment and regeneration of sites
so um
that planned maintenance
budget will be spent on a variety of
different themes it will be spent on
kitchen bathroom refurbs it'll be spent
on retrofit works it might be spent on a
significant project
of a wholestone corner ilk if we
identify such such schemes
yeah that's really helpful thank you um
but then there's a different question
and that is
if it is possible to spend some six
million pounds
uh there are so many properties up out
there that will need a lot of work doing
on them
is some 3.7 3.8 million pounds in future
years
going to be enough or are we are we then
having to delay
um
bringing up to standard so many
properties across the district
because because of lack of
lack of finance
thank you
i i think what i would want to prevent
is to stray into the hra business plan
conversation because i can foresee that
we will be having these conversations um
in in the not too distant future
the reality is um that we have
expectations on that we set on what we
want to achieve with our stock in terms
of decency quality and the like we have
the government imposing on housing
providers the building safety
acts fire safety act
and we're looking ahead to decent homes
too which will be a new standard in
terms of the level of decency that all
social housing needs to meet as well as
those environmental measures as well
naturally if we build a new home there's
a capital outlay but there's also an
income receipt for that property uh week
in week out year and year out invariably
what you're identifying and what i think
we'll be having conversations about with
the cabinet and with yourselves at full
council in regards to the business plan
is there is a significant investment
required in our existing stock
over the long over the medium long term
um so i would estimate that to be
more than 60 million across baby mid
suffolk uh to reach epcc and and and
upwards of 100 million to to meet any
any higher ambitions than than that
clearly that has to be found from
somewhere and as part of the business
plan work we're looking at a variety of
different scenarios in terms of
we've got a finite amount of income
coming into the account um we've got a
number of expenditures and how do we
adjust those uh to fund this work
clearly borrowing is is an example of
where we can bring in additional
receipts
but whatever we borrow has to be
obviously
naturally affordable and i think for for
the hra in the long medium to long term
there are going to be those challenges
and we are going to have to make some
tough decisions on the level of
expenditure on on on our homes and how
we make best use of what we've got
[Music]
yeah i mean i think i think there is
there is a real concern there um
which perhaps is not today is not the
time to address what that concern is and
how we overcome it but i i i wanted to
flag up
that we've got we've got some big bills
coming and they're going to be bigger
than 3.7 3.8 million pounds a year
and
we mustn't we mustn't look at these
figures and think that's going to solve
the problem
we're certainly not going to solve the
problem in three years
uh council marcel uh thank you
given that
what um gavin's just said about the um
energy efficiency measures going into
some of the council properties um
what is actually covered by your line in
the table called environmental
improvements
if they're obviously not um energy
efficiency measures what other sort of
environmental improvements are you
budgeting
for thank you chair thank you councillor
mansell um
apologies by the titles because i think
they can be confusing um our retrofit
program our
sustainable program around our existing
stock would be formed from the planned
maintenance budget and we're actually
creating reserves within that so that
any underspend can be consumed within an
environmental reserve to support those
retrofit works environmental
improvements is actually
works that we what we might want to
undertake to our estates um in terms of
for example increased biodiversity or
changes to to to to the makeup of those
estates um and as i don't want to
preempt the business plan work again but
an example of that is us looking at how
we invest more in those areas
to support the aims and goals of the
organizations and the councils
return to councillor john field
thank you
um
just really questioning the the rising
in rent
obviously yields 580 000 pounds
four percent of
14 million and if you look at over 30
years it raises 17 million which is four
percent of the whatever it is um
uh 450 million that will get in total
revenue over that period so it's not
inconsiderable but i was going to
question the the issues of um
raising the rent of people who are in
the
poorest element typically of society and
we know this year there are substantial
challenges
um i here think i heard that council
whitehead is probably not going to put
up council tax and that's good
for those people but they considerably
have suffered cuts to universal credit
more importantly perhaps at the moment
swinging increases in fuel bills um
heating bills for houses so there's a
question really whether it's responsible
to um
to to raise that uh
to put it introduce that increase
this
financial year in particular
and
one obviously understands the longer
term investment issues but
some of these things like epc
if you introduce changes there you will
reduce people's heating bills so
there's some argument that you could
raise rents at that time without damage
to anyone so it's really is that 4.1
a good thing to be doing this year
thank you council field
coaster white house so perhaps before
handing over to gavin i mean i think
this is the fundamental
question when it comes to when we debate
the hra
in in full council um it is
a large increase four point one percent
although it's three pound thirty four a
week which is what probably 160 pound a
year
um which will be um will not will hurt
people um the i made the point that even
with this increase we are just showing a
very small surplus effectively but
breaking even on this ring fenced
account which has to be self financing
so
to some extent i guess it's between a
rock and a half place with this and i
say i think this will be the fundamental
issue that will need debating in full
council
but gavin you want to add anything in
terms of
thank you councilor whiteheads and uh
castlefield for the question
i think a few points uh of note um
fundamentally we went for a period
between 2015 and 2020 of rent reductions
and i'm conscious this report doesn't
evidence it but i think it would be
helpful possibly for me to go away and
compare rent levels in 2015 to to where
they are now because uh clearly we we're
playing catch up in regards to to those
reductions in recent years um we've also
had the debate and conversation in this
room um around the level of investment
required and that has to be paid for and
and there is a real challenge and i
i 100 wholeheartedly uh agree um in
terms of the challenges that uh we face
um as as as a nation right now in in
terms of rising fuel bills um or or
changes to universal credit
ultimately we have to provide a
sustainable hra
not just for for the forthcoming year
but but for the next 30 years and you
can see the impacts by not increasing
rents and what that would mean and
invariably that means because it's a
very ring-fenced fund
that it would impact the level of
service the level of quality and and and
improvements that we could
we can improve um our tenants um homes
with um we've done a huge amount of
consultation with tenants over the the
summer of last year in relation to the
hra business plan
and we'll be bringing forward through
that work um their commentary their
feedback um
their wants and desires in terms of the
landlord service
and they're ambitious they're ambitious
in terms of what they want but there is
also a level of
expectation that
anyone would expect and i think we
tenders deserve in terms of
a a good quality high quality home a
decent home a home that isn't
isn't damp or moldy a home where the
energy bills are as low as practically
possible
and as such that's got to be funded so
it is is difficult um but we we face
those challenges one thing that we are
going to be doing uh bringing forward in
the first half of this year is a rent
and service charge policy
which i believe will set the direction
of travel for uh for the need to
increase or manage service charges and
manage our income in the longer term so
you can expect to see that policy
come forward over the forthcoming
months
thank you
can i just comment on that please do
please well if it's a question yeah
is it a question i'm just going to point
out that we went through a period a four
year period of rent reductions
because we and others put the rent up
the government didn't like it
particularly the impact on the on the um
social bills that they have to suffer
the the promotion of our tenants whose
rents they pay
so we suffered a period of four years of
reduction
you know i'm also concerned that
we with others obviously not on our own
could provoke just the same sort of
reaction again
we keep sticking rents up the government
will say saw you do that now put them
back down again and they ultimately are
more powerful than we are
thank you
not sure there was a question there but
if there were if you can find a question
there gavin she'll answer it i i think
council field raises a really valid
point and a point i just come back with
is
in terms of self-financing um and the
situation that mid-suffolk found itself
in in 2012 2013 when it's self-financed
and took on a significant financial um
burden in terms of a a a debt um and
clearly in terms of developing and
managing the business plan which is
projected over a 30 period at any one
time
it didn't take into account the ability
that rents would decrease it it took
account of its ability to control its
own finances including its income and
its expenditure
and as such that that rent reduction has
impacted the hra business plan and hence
why we sit here today talking about rent
increases and talking about the levels
of investment that are required in the
long term um
i think fundamentally
we all identify um in in social housing
and uh and in the organizations the
level of investment required the level
of ambition to meet the the climate
emergency that's been declared that
the need and justification for to
provide decent and quality homes um and
that comes at a cost and and that has to
be managed i think what we can evidence
through this budget is actually um we
are optimizing the budget wherever
possible um i spoke to our hra business
plan consultant last week he told us and
he he manages more than 100 hras across
the country that typically we as baby
mid suffolk and individually we're about
250 pounds
cheaper per property um than than any
other um social housing landlord in in
terms of the average and that's around
supervision management and the cost of
repairs so we're already running a very
lean service in my opinion in terms of
in terms of roles and responsibilities
and and what we achieve uh with what
we've got um but those additional monies
that will be received through through
any rent increase will will naturally go
towards these ambitions uh that we've
talked about today and will be set out
in the business plan
thank you
thank you that was useful information
very much
so members
there'd be no more questions who would
like to open the debate
council casting thank you thank you
finishing on that note of the council
house um
rent i do wonder if we need more
information in this paper of where we
are
with them we
said the 250 um
pounds below
market well not market but for council
has a bit of an oxymoron but um the um
the the um the sort of market council
house rent
where we are
um where this will take us
and um
you know i think i think in this paper
to make that decision we do need
a bit more of that information because
it's some 4.1 percent of what
whether it's an already high rent a low
rent bringing it into something that
stays a low rent
for the um for the market i keep saying
the market but
and also the other information i'd like
to know is um
how um
how many of the council house rents
are um the tenants are able to pay their
rent and how many are assisted in any
way because um i think that says quite a
lot about the actual
rent level but just just a
thought for um
what this
this paper going forward
uh so um council casting are you asking
that that information is made available
to members before the council meeting
when this will be debated
yeah i think maybe if if we're going to
make recommendations on this
i'd leave it up to the other members of
this committee but that might be
something that we would like to have
included in the paper before we actually
take it to full council and perhaps
provide it to us next year when we are
looking at the hra budget
in advance of council
is there sort of a general agreement
that that's a good idea
that that's necessary in order to
debate the item
yeah
because
i would think so uh mr chairman um i
think it just just follows the trend of
the discussion we had
about the previous budget so i don't see
why it wouldn't apply in this case
so would we like to see some information
earlier than now and more information
that
that's the
that's the gist of what i'm
understanding
um
so are you uh council caster i mean well
that wasn't really what i was um trying
to say i think um
i think
given the time before this would
actually go to um
full um council i think there's enough
time it's just in this
in this paper when this paper arrives
that at the same time as it has arrived
i'd quite like to see that information
so that
a percentage isn't a rent
uh you know it's it's very hard to
actually work out where we are with that
yeah so i mean what i was suggesting is
that this year that information is made
available between now and the council
meeting and next year it's made
available before the overview and
security meeting so that we have that we
have that
yeah thank you mr chairman yeah no i
agree with that sorry yeah
um
so
if that can be put into a form of words
are you
content to um
note the
note the budget note the the report
note the proposals
um
so councillor casten and councillor
aquino
um and then
if one of our officers has got a form of
words
i think bethany's got something there
typed out
and do you want to compare notes and and
then and then
if you if you compare notes with
henriette then um
sorry
sorry chad
we have that the overview and scrutiny
notes the housing revenue account
2022-23 and four-year outlook and that
information is provided for an overview
our council house
rents collection
for tenants before council in february
and to the oeu and scrutiny committee
before the budget next year or with the
budget next year
is that okay with the proposal and the
secondary
would you like to have it read again
please
it's the second one you need to consider
presumably
yeah
um that dean that information is
provided for an overview of council
house rents collection
it's a comparison that i'm really
looking at it's like um
if um the the percentage
to me isn't hasn't got that much in
information if we were going down the
a14 and i said i was going to drive 10
faster that wouldn't be the important
number it'd be how fast i was going at
that time so um
it's um
what i'd like to see is what maybe um
our surrounding council's council tanks
average rents are
or um you know some examples to see
where ours are to
you know
i
so it's the level of council house rent
compared with similar authorities
yeah not the collection but the level of
the rent
i don't know if this is helpful or not
but um just just some calculations
because three pound three pound thirty
four is a four point one percent
increase so basically it takes the rent
up from 81 pound 46 this is averages 81
46 a week up to 84 pound 80 a week which
is equivalent of 368 pounds per month
which i think most people sort of think
of monthly rents don't particularly in
the private sector so the average our
average rent per month is 368
per month and i guess that compares also
very favorably with the private sector
where i think flats are around the 500
to 600
70s or 700 and bigger houses even more
that certainly helps to put it in
perspective i think i think the point
that we were looking to understand
was
that the average
weekly council house rent paid in
mid-suffolk
that compares with
other authorities not how it compares
with the private sector particularly
counts right beyond
um i'm not sure that's quite correct mr
chairman um at the beginning of of his
commentary uh councillor casten was
concerned i think about the fact that
the level of rent
could be such that it's causing tenants
to then have their rent subsidized
so it was kind of a little bit of a
vicious circle you know on having them
with one hand and taking away with the
other hand and i think his concern is
he can correct me if i'm wrong as to
whether we are setting the rents at a
level
that avoids that really
yeah
absolutely that was the other part of it
so when what i'd what i'd like to see is
a um a comparison to see where our
council tax uh our council rents sit
compared with other authorities and also
look into how many of the residents have
that subsidized
um and where we are with that because i
think i think that is a really important
part of this if um if the residents
can't pay their rent it doesn't matter
how high it is or
you know
it so what we're looking for i think is
the step change in the in the number of
council tenants who would not be able to
pay
their
or would have their rate their rent
subsidised if we went
one percent three point one percent or
four point one i think that sort of a
projection what i'd like to say
see is right now
how
residents need how many residents need
to be assisted with that
um and then we've got information that
like projections aren't particularly you
could say um times are getting harder or
you know i i just that's not really what
i'm looking for
out of our um out of our council house
stock
i'd like to um i'd like to know how many
people are
need assistance with their rent to pay
them in the current year
yeah
because what i thought you were looking
for was how much that would
what how that percentage would increase
if
the
rent increased but you're not no no i
don't think
for me i think it would um
i don't know projections are difficult
things aren't they um
they're um
i i
yeah i mean yes i mean i'm i'm quite
content with going with what you said
i'm not sure how that helps in in um
looking at
the effect of an increase it gives an
idea of where our rents are at the
moment and
what
and how people are managing to pay the
rents at the moment at the moment so if
it's if it's a surprisingly large number
that that says a lot about putting rents
up if um
if it's a low number
um we could
you know that to me is an indicator
yeah that's i think that's very valuable
because we we know that that
as a district council incomes throughout
the district are lower than many of the
surrounding districts so
that would be very useful information
yeah
so
would one of you
read out what you've got on your screen
then please
uh i have that information is provided
for the level of council rent compared
with other authorities for benchmarking
for the current year
be provided to council in february and
to the overu and security committee for
the budget in the next municipal
year i don't think that had the full no
i don't think i had the full full
inclusion just give me a moment please
do you apologize members let's try again
that information is provided for the
level of council rent compared with
other authorities for benchmarking in
the current year and the number of
tenants receiving rent uh rebate in the
current financial year be provided to
council in february and to the ov and
scrutiny committee for their review of
the budget in the next municipal year
it's the seconder and the proposal and
the second are happy with that
right we will not put in modern.gov
we'll just go straight to the vote if
you're happy with that
members happy with that you're content
and so
we can look in modern.gov
to vote
the vote is now in progress chair
i'm afraid it's not letting me vote so
i'm i'm in favor
council mansell can i take your vote
verbally please
councilman it hasn't come up so
can i take you back verbally please
could you let us know what your vote
[Music]
can i breathe verbally
oh okay it's comfortable
that six weights four and that's
unanimous oh that's unanimous thank you
very much indeed
thank you
um
so we move on to
the
item 8 which is the forthcoming
decisions list
do members have any comments on the
forthcoming decisions list please
there are none
thank you the forthcoming decisions list
is just for noting
the mid-suffolk overview of scrutiny
work plans does anyone have any comments
on the work plan please
council mansell
yeah
as a member of the um
uh west suffolk
community safety partnership
and i know that you have your meeting um
on the 21st of march 2022 that relates
to a review of the community safety
partnership
um i am aware that um our review at mid
suffolk does not um coincide
with the programme for other
members of the west suffolk community
safety partnerships review
and i'm just worried that this produces
um extra work for our officers and has
there ever been any consideration of
moving the date
to coincide with um other councils and
other members review
time scale
yes there has been consideration we did
ask the corporate manager if it would be
more convenient for her and for the
community safety partnership
um and i believe that she indicated that
she would be happy with it to stay
um
yeah i mean we have we have asked the
question and we can ask that question
again
so perhaps
we will we will note that we will check
with the
corporate manager and ask the corporate
managers to check with the com with the
partnership
okay thank you very much
so we now move on to
the call in item 10.
um yeah we just need five minutes in
order to
um
rearrange the room a touch
so shall we have a break no just for
five
thank you um welcome back to the meeting
we are now moving on to
item 10
which is the calling of a mid suffer
cabinet decision on the 6th of december
and at item 10
members you asked to consider and
approve the protocol for the call-in
so
just to add a little bit to that um
i'm going to read out
uh when we start item 11 the full
discussion of this call-in i'm going to
read out in full
the calling notice for the benefit of
anybody who's watching in
because they won't have the papers
and also
at
i'm going to ask uh
the monitoring officer to
expand a bit on item 4.6
where it sets out the the options that
we have
and just to clarify
i don't think it's necessary but at 4.2
i will invite you to
ask questions of offices and members of
cabinet but only on
matters of their portfolio but we have
only one
we only have one portfolio holder here
and i think this all is within her
portfolio so i don't think that will be
a problem
so could i just ask um the monitoring
officer to expand on 4.6 and after that
i would i'm going to ask you to
confirm that you're content with the
protocol
thank you chair um committee in
accordance with the council's procedure
rules for call-ins the committee is
obliged to consult with the monitor
officer as to whether the decision by
the cabinet was contrary to or not
wholly in accordance with the policy
framework or the budget
and this is scrutiny procedure rule 12.8
part 3 section 1 subsection 2 if anybody
would like to look that up
if the decision was contrary to policy
or budget the committee could resolve to
refer the matter to the full council for
a final decision
if it's not contrary to policy or budget
then your options are to either accept
the decision as made by the cabinet or
to refer the matter back to the cabinet
for review
chair would you like me at this stage to
give my advice on whether or not he is
consistent
please do
firstly i would like to confirm to the
committee that the adoption of the
hackney carriage and private hire
vehicle licensing policy
is an executive function under the terms
of the local authority's functions and
responsibilities england regulations
and and the council's constitution
therefore the cabinet was the correct
decision maker for this matter
secondly it is my view as monitoring
officer that the decision taken by the
cabinet was in accordance with the
council's agreed policy framework and
budget
and therefore it is not possible for
this committee to refer this matter to
the full council
chairman this means that if after your
deliberations the committee is of the
view that the cabinet's decision was
flawed the appropriate recommendation is
to refer the matter back to the cabinet
for further consideration
clearly setting out the issues that the
committee would like to see addressed
thank you thank you very much
so i will i will now
ask you to confirm you're happy with the
protocol
so we will proceed
do we
we don't we need to vote
so
those in favor are we are we doing this
electronically as well
those in favor of
sorry
yeah
we accept i probably can't and there may
be others who can't for whatever reason
are you are you content
we'll do this by a show of hands
those in favor of adopting the protocol
for the calling
thank you very much that's unanimous
oh did we need a proposal with a second
as well
oh sorry about that right
mr chairman is it just the committee
voting on this yeah okay
i i i thought that this was well anyway
we've got to propose a council scarf
we've got a second to councillor mansell
we are still all in favor yeah
thank you
i'm sorry that was my fault i didn't
realize that it wasn't just
straightforward that we had to adopt it
so we press on
and
the calling
is as follows
the following counselors whose names
i'll read out at the end agree that the
covenant decision taken on monday the
6th of december 2021
to adopt the post-consultation draft
hackney carriage and private hire
vehicle licensing policy should be
called in for scrutiny for the following
reasons
one the covenant report mca 2132 stated
at 11
environmental implications 11.1
the recommendation to switch to hybrid
and fully electric vehicles could mean
that either the hackney carriage ranks
in the mid-suffolk district
need to be adapted or infrastructure
will be needed
nearby to support the change to greener
energy efficient vehicles
this statement appears to only consider
some potential infrastructure
implications and does not encompass or
examine the wider environmental
implications of the proposed policy
the council declared a climate emergency
motion in july 2019
which stated the aim which stated the
aim to work with partners towards the
aspiration of making the county of
suffolk carbon neutral by 2030
however the prop the proposed new policy
proposes little that moves hackney
carriages and private hire vehicles
toward more environmentally friendly or
zero carbon choices apart from the
strong recommendation
that new taxis should be electric
vehicles or hybrids
there is no deadline by which these
changes should be made and no support or
encouragement offered to assist owners
to adapt
the new policy states at six one one
that the council
will look to research and develop an
incentive scheme
however no plan or timetable is
presented to take this forward
it is not shown how the policy
contributes towards the council's stated
aim of achieving carbon neutrality by
the cabinet made a decision to adopt the
policy without a full description a full
depiction of the debate on
the draft report which had taken place
at the licensing and regulatory
committee on 16th of august 2021 where
opposition members
pressed for electric vehicles and
hybrids to be given a higher priority in
the recommendations
those calls were not accepted and the
draft report was eventually voted
through on the chairs casting vote
cabinet members did not explore or seek
to understand why some members of the
licensing or regulator and regulatory
committee had been unable to support the
draft policy when it was debated on
august 16th
and this call-in was agreed by the
following councillors e burn field
matheson mellon norris otton pratt
stringer and war boys
so i've introduced the call-in
and we now move on to
[Music]
um
the
the lead the lead signatory which i
think is councillor mellon
we'll now present the reason for the
calling and why the committee should
scrutinize the decision
this will be up to a maximum of 10
minutes which the clerk will time
the lead signatory may choose to call
other councillors from those listed in
the calling notice
but the maximum amount of time will
remain 10 minutes collectively
so it's over to you councilman
thank you chair
the cabinet is the place where um many
decisions are formally made and whilst
there are only nine councillors on it
other councillors can attend meetings to
listen
to ask questions and whilst we don't get
a vote it's an opportunity for the
opposition to do its job
and that is monitoring scrutinizing and
challenging
the administration
we see this as an opportunity to improve
decision-making and ensure the best
outcome for the people of mid-suffolk
this call-in is the first one to have
been done during this council term in
fact the first one for several years
and the reasons for doing so have been
set out in the call-in request that
you've just heard
i will go briefly through them now with
the help of my colleague councillor
stringer
we do accept that a lot of hard work has
gone into the proposed policy by
officers and counsellors
however the heart of the matter is this
we do not feel the cabinet had all the
information needed on the new hackney
carriage and private hire vehicle policy
in order to make a good decision on the
6th of december and hence we
respectfully
suggest that they need to have another
look at it
also we do not feel that the decision to
adopt this policy is compliant with
other policies of the council
specifically the july 29
2019 declaration of a climate emergency
that was agreed
unanimously by all councillors
so i'll just take you briefly through
the two reasons for the call-in
the first one is the environmental
implications and only one
is listed and that is about the
provision of infrastructure which is
arguably not
an environmental implication
clearly electrical vehicles and to a
lesser extent plug-in hybrids will need
to have charging infrastructure in order
to operate
however there are many more
environmental implications which are not
addressed in the report
for example
diesel engines and older petrol engines
emit particulates such as pm 2.5 which
are known to be harmful to human health
in general diesel and petrol cars emit
carbon dioxide in higher amounts per
mile than their hybrid or ev equivalents
and of course evs in particular are zero
emission at the
tailpipe earlier switching to these
vehicles would mean reductions in co2
emissions and other pollutants
the government has set 2030 as the
deadline where no petrol or diesel cars
can be bought
and obviously 2030 is also a significant
date for this authority and that's the
next point
of the call-in
the proposed policy proposes little that
moves hackney carriages and private high
vehicles towards
more environmentally friendly or zero
carbon choices apart from a strong
recommendation and this is where the
proposed taxi policy is clearly at odds
with another policy and that is the
overarching aspirations of carbon
neutrality by 2030
if we are to achieve this ambitious
target it can't all be done at the end
there needs to be a progression towards
that goal over the eighth years that
remain
with deadlines along the way
for example you could say after 2024 no
new diesel vehicle will be licensed or
after 2027 only vehicles emitting less
than 100 grams of carbon per kilometer
will be licensed
operators would adapt if given time to
plan but what they don't need is a
sudden change in the rules later on
however the proposed policy only
recommends a change to hybrid or
electric vehicles
there is an opportunity here to steer
operators in the right direction using a
combination of carrot and stick however
no specific carrots or sticks
are proposed
and the second part of the calling is to
do with the
the debate that was had uh prior to this
coming to to cabinet
at the cabinet
on the 6th of december the new policy
was simply introduced as having been
agreed by the licensing committee
and i think cabinet members may have
taken a different view had they been
aware that there had been an extended
debate on those proposals
and that the draft policy only been
voted through on the chairs casting vote
and i'll now hand over to my colleague
councillor stringer who was a
participant in that debate at licensing
committee on the 16th of august
thank you councillor mellon and and
thank you for the ability to speak to
this calling
and
i sometimes apologize for calling things
in but i perhaps
at times think we don't do it often
enough because it does actually focus
our minds on on particular issues
we're acutely aware that within the
cabinet system that the authorities
delegated to a number of people to carry
out decisions uh on behalf of the
council
but the quality of those decisions is
directly proportionate to the amount of
accurate information
going into that decision-making process
and we certainly feel that in this case
had
more information gone into that process
that the outcome
may have been different
even if it was still in agreement but
somehow nuanced and that comes out of
the debate that was held
at the original licensing meeting
and subsequent freedom of information
requests
where we now learn more about the
timetable of events
both of those sets of documents have
been submitted to this meeting but
because of how late the foi timetable
was it's been ruled that we can't you
can't see them today because they were
only
with us yesterday
anyway that aside
going back to the
why the decision may be flawed is is
that extra information
in the timetable of looking at this
licensing policy
you need to put in the public domain
and with the trade what the likely hood
travel is within the policy
and what policies will be in it
so before we went to public consultation
before even the panel that the licensing
panel had looked at here
we had taken the decision
to strip out of the consultation
a compulsory move
to lower emission vehicles
which means
the trade didn't get to debate that with
us
and we then didn't we hadn't had a
debate about that at our meeting but
then the legal representation
then ruled that you can't add that now
because that would be a wholly different
policy which you haven't consulted on
so
even from the start if we wanted to
help
or compel the trade to go to zero
emission vehicles it was already holed
below the water line before we started
because it had been removed from the
original consultation
so
even if the cabinet had said no no no
we've declared a climate emergency we
are going to move to zero emissions
vehicles
faster than the government is saying we
have to by law
they wouldn't have been able to do it
because of it had been it had been ruled
out of the discussion before we even had
the discussion
which is worrying
that's why the debate
at the licensing hearing ended up quite
split
and why it was a very difficult decision
at that hearing and if you read the
transcript of the of the debate actually
i'm really plea it was a really good
debate i have to say and there's a few
members of of that committee that here
today and i thank you for a really good
debate but i think the decision
the final
thing that triggered those members for
not insisting on
exploring that zero emission
pathway earlier
was because
of the legal advice that came in to say
you haven't consulted on it therefore
we can't it's a whole new policy so
you'll have to go through the whole
framework again
also
within uh not put in front of the
decision makers
was the risk
of
it was highlighted the risk of
compelling to move to a zero emission
taxi licensing policy
but what also wasn't put in front of
the committee was the risk
in in having no framework to do that
transitions to new technologies normally
happen on something called s-curves
which means that
the migration to a newer technology
doesn't happen incremental
it happens on an s-curve and the
migration to electric vehicles and
zero-emission vehicles is moving along a
perfect s-curve
two years ago
zero emission and low emission vehicles
were four percent of the market in 2022
that's that's that yearly target is now
up to do you have one twenty percent one
minute left thank you keith uh cancer
will i'm sorry uh
that is highly likely to not be gradual
lift it's it's like to be on an s curve
which is going to be even steeper which
means our
taxi service and those having licenses
will need support in that migration
because if they do delay the transition
they may be economically disadvantaged
and that risk was not debated by the
cabinet so that's why we would suggest
that a decision at cabinet was flawed
because of an element of the process and
not all of the relevant information
being put in front of them thank you
chair thank you very much
i now call on the cabinet member to
present the reasons why the decision
taker was taken by cabinet
and you have 10 minutes as well
thank you very much and um
thank you for the opportunity to speak
about this
this call in
um
i will say that i am disappointed that
some members have seen fit to call in
the draft hackney care and public hire
licensing policy this document is the
result of extensive consultation and
much hard work by our officers
in close accord with local providers
also the licensing committee in august
approved the policy
where a question concerning support for
evs was posed and answered an almost
identical question was put to me at the
6th of december cabinet meeting by
councilman
melon
which i also answered
it is relevant that the main objectives
of this policy
are to provide a uniform set of
standards and expectations
for the taxi and phv trade and protect
the public in terms of safety and
security and ensure that there is a
reasonable access to taxi and services
for all users in the district that is
the main objective of this policy
to clarify my understanding of aspects
in dispute i understand the main issues
relate to the desire for a mandatory
timetable for transition to evs and that
the wider implications of this
transition were not fully considered the
call-in also mentions incentives
to transition to evs and this incentive
scheme
it seeks a plan and timetable the
details of such a scheme we've already
agreed to prepare
these need to be worked up separately
though to the policy and is an action i
fully support
work behind developing the policy
indicated a significant risk from an
accelerated mandatory approach to
transition that could lead in fact to
fewer taxis providing a more expensive
service
which would be a huge loss both socially
and environmentally and counter to our
aims to achieve carbon neutrality by
twenty thirty
the hackney care and public hire
providers are in a vulnerable position
in this area given the pandemic and the
reduction in passengers using public
transport and getting around
that they provide a valuable and
necessary service to residents and
businesses is undisputed and both their
viability and their capacity to provide
affordable services are central to our
economy and to the functioning of
society here in general
licensees offer a commercial service
and they need as much freedom as
possible to operate
this policy will be reviewed again in
three years
and the question of fuel transition will
be examined then
along with other relevant matters
follow and following an extensive
consultation
for our local providers at this time the
transition away from fossil fuels
and the interests of the environment
which we all in this room i think want
will be more successful if pursued
through encouragement rather than
mandate
and this approach is reflected in the
policy
i believe that cabinet had more than
adequate information about which to make
its decision and that the policy should
be taken forward as it stands
thank you
the next
next stage is for
the committee members
to ask questions of the lead signatory
and the cabinet member for further
information clarification this is
so
does any
does any member
seek any further clarification council
repping young
thank you mr chairman um
it would appear to me at least that um
the the movers of the call-in uh are in
contradiction in terms of their claim
with the comments that have been made by
the cabinet member
for the environment
and essentially i'd like to understand
whether or not indeed
in creating the policy we didn't
consult with the trade about the move
uh to zero emissions of vehicles
thank you
yes could yes please
fleming
um yes um counselor we did and
the results of the consultation are
available they were part of the
cabinet report in december i've read
them all
and
none of the
comments coming back from providers
asked for
support for transition to an electric
vehicle or hybrid
environment however we do understand
that they're very interested in it
because they're
less expensive to run
and i think it's been made clear all
along that the district stands to help
and support the trade wherever we
possibly can to transition but we had a
strong response during the consultation
that a mandate would backfire badly and
not be in in the interests of either the
environment
or the public
perhaps could i follow on what so i'm
not sure whether there was formal
concept consultation with taxi drivers
about what effect a mandatory um
imposition of uh evs or evs and hybrids
would have had was there was there
actually a question in the formal
consultation
about
that
um
no but you have to remember what the
main purpose of this policy is is to
provide a safe and effective service for
the for residents
yeah i do understand that
um
i mean what what i'm trying to
understand is
the desire to provide a safe and
effective
service to residents
in line with
all of the district council's policies
that's that's that's that's where i've
got a blockage in my in my understanding
i'm not sure where your blockage is
counselor
well
i believe that we have a policy
to to to
become as a district carbon neutral by
and that i would have expected
any developing policy or protocol or
procedure to have borne that in mind and
i'm not i'm not understanding how
the
this that that desire that policy
that determination to become carbon
neutral
um was
uh
part of the discussion around
development of the
uh of the
of the consultation document
i will bring in um
you know the officer cass clemens
because i had had several discussions
about this in fact as i understand
originally
the approach was to mandate
a replacement service over i think
a time period but this did not go down
well with the service providers which is
why
we took the position we did in the
more final draft to remove that because
it would have been as we understood
harmful to the providers of the service
to have mandated a transition and we did
indeed have many discussions about it
yeah cass
i think council of feminists just said
almost exactly what i was going to say
so so just to to follow on from that
slightly then um
and to confirm there was not a specific
question purely about a mandatory in
time frame or implementation around evs
and hybrids so there was a part the
whole policy trade can converse with us
on any part but clearly the policies as
councillor fleming set out about the
safety and the provision of the service
undoubtedly had that question been
in that consultation
the trade quite rightly i think would
have said to us
what about infrastructure which i think
is what all of us say about evs and
hybrids currently um
and i totally agree with them they
invest tens of thousands of pounds in
their vehicles and a mandatory clause
would be telling them to do that again
perhaps
sooner than they would have done so so
the infrastructure question is
absolutely the right one
so
i do agree i think a timetable should be
developed to look at what a mandatory um
clause would be within our policy but we
cannot do that in isolation and i'm this
is not to try to pass the buck this is
about having to work in partnership with
other partners who have responsibilities
we need to draft that timetable along
with suffolk county council because they
have the responsibility for on-street ev
charging and they also dictate taxi
ranks where they are
and we are just a
a console t in terms of where they go so
i think we need to develop that policy
with suffolk and along with the trade to
look at what that time scale is i think
someone earlier in ons used the term
rock and a hard place we have a massive
aspiration and a
responsibility to get to 2030 and we
also have a trade here who is already
suffering through the pandemic and
we are going to put a financial burden
on if we don't get that right so i think
what we were
aiming for through this is to have an
opportunity to work with everyone to
look at what the time scale would be for
that mandatory clause in terms of
hybrids and evs
thank you uh council mansell
thank you chair um
listening to what you've just said about
removing uh one of the policies from the
consultation document
and what you've just said um are you not
prejudging what the trade would have
said by by your response just now
surely you should have given them the
chance to respond themselves rather than
prejudging what you think they might put
in a consultation document
um
the munching officer
thank you i just wanted to step in
before officers replied to that point
because i think we are veering away from
the purpose of the calling
here i think the question about whether
the process of making the decision might
include reference to adequate
consultation being undertaken
but it's not for this committee to
scrutinize whether or not certain
questions should have been included in
the consultation
um so i think
this line of questioning is probably
veering away from your scope in terms of
the um
the call-in reasons
and scrutinizing the disc the the
process of decision making by the
cabinet
rather than by the licensing committee
thank you thank you
council mansell but because i was i
wasn't sure if a question i had was was
for the for in this stage of the process
or or
to ask questions of the officers because
i was going to say if one of our options
is to
refer this back to cabinet
but if cabinet have the same information
what is the difference
um and as councillor stringer mentioned
in his
representation he felt that that
something had been missed from a
consultation
you're saying now i just want to confirm
that you're not saying that we can make
a suggestion that it should go back for
another round of consultation we can't
do that is that what you're saying we
can only send it back to cabinet and the
cabinet will have exactly the same
information
um chair if i may i'm i'm not saying
that um what i'm saying is that if you
are going to refer the decision back to
cabinet and you're going to ask them to
look at additional information you may
want to specify that that means
further consultation but it's not for
debate now as to whether the questions
asked previously were the right
questions or not
so you can
identify if that's the will of the
committee that insufficient information
was considered by the cabinet and if
that's the case then
further consultation might be a way of
gaining that additional information
thank you
counselor scarf
it's an interesting point i mean my
question would be then
were the cabinet aware in the original
consultation it was mandated but removed
were they aware of the reasoning as to
whether that actually occurred
did they know that it was mandated in
the previous consultation did they have
the full information when they made the
decision
yes cass
oh yeah i think i can answer that
question so so yes cabinet we're aware
so in appendix b of the report that went
to cabinet it showed that amendments
were made following an informal
consultation with the trade that took
place in july 2020 where those concerns
about a mandatory clause were voiced by
the trade so they were they this wasn't
an assumption by offices it was
following a conversation with the trade
and that was included in the cabinet
report
thank you
the council scarf
well i i know we're discussing the
decision made by the cabinet but
the question also would be were the
license in a regulatory committee aware
of
the fact that there was it was mandated
in the original consultation or not
perhaps the officer can just confirm i
know i don't want to stray out of the
area of what we're looking at but i'm
just interested in the background
information that went to the two
decision making bodies
so i could confirm yesterday the
licensing committee were aware of um
those conversations that was
all the information that was available
it seems from
a response to an earlier question that
to a degree the district council's hands
are tied
because the county council have to agree
where the taxi ranks go and where
on street ev charging
has to be
but the county council
have no say on where off street ev
charging has to be
and
has no say in whether or not
the district council can provide ev
charging either free or at cost
and were were the cabinet aware of those
matters
um i can just say um
i don't know i haven't asked them but i
do know that
going forward with this strategy
of this policy
assuming we can take it forward
promptly
that
we will be looking at the provision of
taxi ranks which i think is is is a real
issue actually in the district um we
need to and
we will be working with the county
council to identify new suitable
locations for ranks along with that goes
an assessment of the need for ev
charging and working with the council to
put these in
my view is we need to do that
in the next year or two and look at this
strategy when it is reviewed again in
three years time
and then reconsider the question of
whether or not
there is a basis for mandating a
transition to what is essentially um a
commercial
organ operation and i would also
question the legality of doing this as
well
if certain providers don't wish to
purchase
more expensive ev vehicles
i'm
sorry i'm not quite clear in my mind
um
cancer scarf
well i'm interested in that last point
because
other local authorities have already
mandated their taxi fleets to be
completely eevee or hybrid
so i don't think there's any doubt that
it's legally possible otherwise other
districts borrowers towns etc wouldn't
have already done it
so i think i think that's rather an
erroneous statement that was that was
the point that i was struggling with
i i've simply raised it as a point i'm
not aware of any um court cases where
this was disputed but um
i i you know i rest my case so to speak
i am not confident
um that if it were disputed in court
that the district has standing to
mandate that kind of
change
i would have i would have thought that
that was a key point for cabinet to be
aware of sorry um
so
why why wasn't
why wasn't that investigated before this
went to cabinet
because it wasn't proposed
but but but it had been raised at
licensing but but the fact that it had
been raised at licensing wasn't put into
the
so i'm sorry you're confused it's it was
raised during early consultation in july
before the licensing committee
but was it was it raised by members of
the licensing committee
no
so they did not they didn't raise
they didn't raise any issues around
eevee and uh
and hybrid and making them either an
encouragement or making them mandatory
i i think they did of course it was
discussed at the meeting
so it was discussed at the
meeting and it was a very
narrow decision on the chairman's vote
but i wonder whether the cap the report
that went to cabinet
conveyed the feeling of the meeting and
the closeness of the of this discussion
and voting
um
i believe the legalities point is is not
directly relevant to the discussion
today it is purely speculative on my
path
however i do
object
in many ways to forcing
expensive
changes on
a segment of of an industry that's very
vulnerable and that is the main thread
that this
policy
reflects
and i think we can all be sensitive to
um the difficult time that our taxing
private hire
providers are having at the moment
um council is struggling with
we're at the point where we are asking
questions of
of the lead signatory and
uh you'll have a
between you'll have an opportunity to
make further points
um later on
councilman mansell
could i ask um
the um
council stringers he was a member of the
licensing committee where they made the
discussion discussion were they made
aware of the informal
process which we've heard the officer
and the cabinet member talk about
informing their decision to remove this
policy from the consultation the
official consultation thank you thank
you in in the document there was
reference to informal consultation but
what was not in there was how
comprehensive that was and how it ranged
and within that there certainly wasn't
the
exploration
of
the threat to continue to have the most
polluting vehicles as part of the fleet
ie non-migration because there is still
the assertion and we've heard it here
again today
that converting to an electric vehicle
is quote more expensive
when all of the evidence
suggests that as we sit here today that
the cost total cost of ownership is
actually equal
thank you
so are there any further questions
no further questions
well in that case the next the next
stage
is to invite the cabinet member
and then the leads lead signatory to
provide a summary of their respective
cases
each are allowed five minutes
so councillor fleming
um
thank you well i
don't feel i need to repeat
what i've said already however what um
i would add is that um
that in the interests of
practically
opera um successful
and um environmentally
secure service we need to approve this
strategy because
if we don't
it will be delayed by probably six
months to a year and i don't see that as
being in anyone's interest
it's because it would
need to go back and be reviewed etc just
this policy
is the result of as i said a lot of work
some of it informal not all of it
formally presented on every aspect if it
was then i think the mountain of
information that the committees would
need to review would be significantly
greater than has been the case because
what we
what i think is happening in this room
there has
been an emphasis on one particular
aspect of the private hiring taxi
policy which is whether or not it should
be there should be a mandatory
ev
transition date now
if you read the policy
most of it is about how the taxing
private hire operators should go about
their daily business and what the public
can expect in in terms of its safety
and
comfort
and accessibility that is what this
policy is about
now if we had included all of the um to
balance this
all of the
backup information conversations emails
etc that went on behind all of these
aspects you would have a mountain to
read
i believe this policy is very balanced
and i would urge
um members of this overview and scrutiny
committee to please think carefully and
get behind the strategy so that we can
move on and actually do the things that
that you're
asking for here in this room
thank you
i'm councillor mellon
thank you chad
um i can agree with um castle fleming
that much of the policy
the over overwhelming majority of the
policy is good and is well considered
and is acceptable
but with the limited levers that are
disposable to move in a greener
direction and here is one
that we've chosen not to pull on and i
feel that the cabinet decision
represents a lost opportunity
and we think it could be revisited
it seems to me that priority
was given to harmonizing the policy with
that of our sister council in baba
and not to harmonizing this with our our
wider environmental objectives
potentially we will need to provide
incentives to these operators but no
timetable is proposed when these
incentives will come in
the question of affordability
has come up
and of course we we all know that the
costs of diesel and petrol
have shot up in the last few months
um
yes the costs of electric charging have
gone up as well but nothing like
as much and i think we we've sort of
teased out from the questions that the
um the earlier proposals
for mandating um the change were not
fully consulted on
um
there would have been pushback from the
trade i think that really is speculation
unless you can back it up uh with some
formal responses
so just to sum up um
i i feel that the uh
the the opportunity is here to revisit
that decision and to come up with
something better thank you chair thank
you
i think at this point
wherever i am in my in my script
do we not now have to ask the
um
the lead
the lead signatory and the member the
cabinet member to leave the meeting
and then
is it just the just those two persons
sorry i have no other opportunity to
make any other points
yes
thank you
okay
so we've heard
from
the two members
who signed the calling we've heard from
the cabinet member and the officer
um
who would like to open the debate
counselor cast and then cancel back me
on
um
we don't want to force people
into um
into changing that disproportionately
affects the poorest and the new younger
drivers coming in counselors said that
it's actually cost neutral you basically
as soon as you get an electric car you
spend more
on the outback and then you're roughly
saving about 60 the cost per mark these
cars are doing
half a million miles
the uh
there's that upfront cost that's
damaging to a young operator a new
person going into this so you want
somebody that's struggling that doesn't
have the cash flow that's that's what
does the harm i'm sure
you know other
other areas which are ever where there's
a little bit more money in it um it
doesn't mean that mid suffolk can just
just put it in and force people to do it
i
for me
i can understand why this was brought in
people are worried they want to hit
the net zero they want to um you know
there's there's not much time to um go
with that but when that infrastructure
is in place when we've got a 250
kilowatt
charging point around every corner that
these
these vehicles don't have to park and
charge for 12 hours to um
to go out again when all that's in place
this will just happen
but forcing it now or i i think you
would just see
the um
the the infrastructure unable to catch
up i think the um i think the cabinet
have made a good decision on this in my
views
thank you mr chairman
um
i i too uh would not be in favor of uh
of this call-in uh
i think
having listened to uh the proposers
and the the comment back from the
cabinet member
responsible for this policy
it seems to me that um
the relevant amount of
consultation and information wasn't made
made available to cabinet in order for
them to make the decision and it seems a
reasonably good decision to make
i think we also need to understand that
we're talking about this
uh against a much wider background of of
government policy which is driving us
all to
go towards um net zero uh in 2030 and
i'm sure that the trade and the
individuals within the trade are very
well aware of this as we all are i mean
i'm i'm actually looking to get an ev
vehicle and indeed you know the cost is
one of my considerations but
what we do see and what we are seeing is
that as um
council stringer pointed out in his
commentary that the the volume of uh
plug-in car plug-in hybrid cars and
electric vehicles is
zooming up i mean every major
manufacturer is delivering a model
literally every month
that's the first thing so the
availability of them is increasing
because the availability is increasing
the costs are coming down because
they're being made in bigger volumes so
the affordability issue is also on on a
timeline and i'm sure that you know
people are factoring that into their
plans for when they make the transition
and i don't think that um this authority
should be mandating whether someone
changes his car next year or the year
after or the year after that they're all
very well aware that if they want to
have a proper viable business in the new
zero emissions
environment they need to make sure they
have the right equipment to do that with
okay so
i think it's a bit of a moot point
uh this whole issue about the the
mandating of the trade to do x y and z i
don't think we should be doing any such
thing i think much more importantly is
what voice can we
put to our partners the county council
and anybody else about actually
improving the infrastructure to enable
not just that trade but the rest of us
to really feel comfortable about going
to electric vehicles i think that's much
more important by any stretch of the
imagination and and so to me this this
calling
is not relevant uh and i don't think
this committee should be uh
referring it to anybody else or or
rather back to cabinet as was uh
directed by
emily
and finally i think
um you know
let's be let's be clear
in certain
instances
you can't say well you know for example
in stone market i'm going to move the
stacks rank from where they are to some
other place because actually they're in
convenient locations what actually you
need to be doing is saying well in those
locations how am i going to make
charging available and there are already
technologies on the market that make
that feasible i mean if you've been into
into some of our bigger cities in recent
times but you can now basically provide
ev charging off electric lamppost so to
me
this is not going in the right direction
at all i mean i think we've got bigger
issues to worry about and so i would not
be supporting this
thank you uh counselor all of us next
and then councillor mansell yes thank
you very much uh chair uh i totally
agree with my colleagues councillor
caston and caterer ethanyong i too
cannot support this this calling i think
the uh the report presented the cabinet
and the comments made by cassandra and
the cabinet member were fair and
accurate and i know for a fact that
there is a lot of work going on behind
the scenes to try and work towards going
towards eevee and hybrid vehicles i
totally disagree with making it
mandatory
uh i don't think that's the right answer
from feedback i get from people who use
taxis sometimes it's very difficult to
hold a taxis you know they haven't got
the staff to to run them or operate them
and i think we need to take that into
account as well do we want to drive more
people away from that profession no we
don't we need those taxis they're very
relevant you know particular people who
you know
can't use public transport etcetera
so no i i don't support this i totally
support the cabinet recommendation and
um i'm happy with what the cabinet say
thank you chief thank you councilman
thank you chair uh
maybe i'm uh as a bit of a newbie on
overview and scrutiny uh i don't think
we're here to remake the decision of the
cabinet
we're here to think about whether they
had all the facts in front of them when
they made that decision i'm not going to
pass a judgment on whether i think um
taxi firms should be mandated or not
that's not what we're here to do what
we're here what i see as our role today
is to decide whether they had all the
information that they needed when they
came to that decision
and i i mean
the only thing i am going to say about
the actual decision
is this the the phrase strong
recommendation
um to move towards more environmentally
um
more environmentally friendly vehicles
given that there was a discussion at
yesterday's planning committee about
wording of conditions and and things
like strongly recommend and um as much
as possible and things like that are
very much open to interpretation and i
i'm not keen on on the wording strong
recommendation but it's not for me to
write that policy and it's not for me to
make the decision of the cabinet but i
do have concerns about the fact that
there was seem to be some informal
consultation which wasn't fully reported
to the decision makers
so um
i feel that i do support this call-in
thank you thank you
council scarf
um thank you chair i mean this is this
is a really interesting one i think
uh for me
there seems to have been two
consultations one consultation as to
this is what we're likely to put in the
consultation then the formal
consultation and that seems to have
muddied the waters quite a lot it was
quite illuminating that in the first
proposal we were actually going to
mandate it anyway
i think there's some assumptions about
the pushback from the trade if it was in
the consultation because i think it
it really is all about carrot and stick
i think if we were going to put it in
the consultation that we're we're minded
to mandate by the end of the next three
year period
to electric vehicle charging and
and and we are prepared to work with you
in terms of incentivisation i think that
would have been a lot a lot stronger um
there's a comment made about we don't
want to force drivers to do it but of
course the government is forcing drivers
to do it it's just a case of when they
do it
um
so
i think the
i think as the volume is increasing
rapidly we've already heard that um
20 now
i i fear by the time that we get to the
end of the three-year period that volume
would increase so rapidly that the
infrastructure won't exist and i i just
think
i i'm minded to support another look by
the cabinet at this decision
thank you
well i have to say when i first read the
papers i was in two minds i i could i
could see i could see the reason why
cabinet had made the decision they had
but i have to say that after
hearing councillor fleming's responses
to questions
i
i now see that there could well be quite
a lot of information that cabinet should
have been given
um
yet we're not here to decide whether or
not there should be a mandate we're here
in respect of ev and hybrid we're here
to
decide whether or not we feel that
sufficient information was given and
i've come down to the to the view that
there was more information that could
have been given
and i think that that information was
around the extent of the
pre-consultation
and also
we've we've heard information about how
um
mid suffolk um are planning to well
they're
not immediate plans but they're planning
to provide taxi ranks and charging
points
now i think i think that if
if in the in the consultation
exercise there had been
some information around
the district
being minded to provide taxi ranks off
street and also to provide charging
points off street
then
that information should have gone to the
taxi firms and
and their responses to that information
should have been given it given to
cabinet
charging doesn't have to be a taxi rank
there can be you can have a taxi rank at
say a station and a charging point
somewhere else in a car park behind the
taxi office or something like that
so
i i feel that cabinet could have been
given more information
um
and i think i think it's more important
to get it right than it is to get the to
get the policy out there in a hurry and
so
i'm i'm coming down in favor of it going
back to cabinet
and for this other information to be
made available
counselling young
uh mr chairman i i'm a bit concerned
because you seem to
be indicating that the cabinet didn't
have some particular elements of
information
and i'm really rather doubtful that
that's a substantial you can substitu
substantiate that claim
um
i mean cabinet
explores these decision-making issues in
in quite a lot of depth officers are
employed
to do investigations and analysis and
provide that information to cabinet so
if there was indeed some kind of failure
of in of of information flow then i
guess that's something that
would need to be investigated but quite
frankly um
none of what we've heard here today
suggested that was the case so i i i
would take issue with with your
statement i'm afraid well that's fine i
mean i i i would say that there's
nothing that we've heard today convinces
me that they were that there wasn't
information there that could have been
given to cabinet and should have been
given the cabinet so i feel we've got to
disagree on that
um
council casting
so this is um this seems to me a lot of
this pointing to a consultation on
whether taxi drivers or operators
woodham
would be willing to um
accept a move over to
evie
which um
for me isn't
the sort of information that makes a
huge difference you'd have to
you'd have to
consult every single taxi driver to make
it fair so you don't just catch the ones
that are about that are willing to do a
survey that have got the time on their
hands and the the
we were talking about disproportionately
affecting youngsters they have young
families and everything they don't have
time to
do these surveys it wouldn't give you
information that would um put put it
either way there's so there's so many
much other information you could look at
in this and we could sit here all day
looking at different things that we
could consult on to make this decision
cabinet members need to make a decision
on their own research not just the
papers in front of them and make that
sound judgment and i i trust that
they've done that in this a case in this
occasion and um i think this is a sound
piece of work i just this
this one consultation that we we've got
hung up on here
i just i just don't see
the value in that it's just you know
there's some
it unless you're going to find out what
every single taxi driver really thinks
you're you're never going to pick up the
people that need it that aren't quite
there money-wise and
all that it's some i've um
i've got a young child and i'm rushing
around with my job i don't ever do a
consultation on anything farming
but
a lot of the older richer farmers do
it's some it's just nonsense
there's some i
i just
you know where i am on this i just um i
just don't really understand
how this one bit of information changes
the whole decision
well i think there's more to it than
just the mandate but um and yeah
i
i'm not going to speak on behalf of a
young taxi driver but i don't think we
should assume that only rich old taxi
drivers fill in consultation forms
um
council mansell
well i just wanted to come back on uh on
councillor caster's comments there
because because i'm sorry we were
actually
um discussing
an informal consultation that the
officers had done before it went to
licensing um
and that's why that particular statement
had been removed and i personally would
have far more faith that a formal
consultation that went out to all taxi
firms in the district
should have a more comprehensive set of
responses than some informal uh
consultation about which we know very
little because who knows they may have
only asked the old elderly retired taxi
drivers in the informal consultation if
it was informal and it wasn't recorded
how do we know who they asked
and that and that's really my
my my bone about it uh and yes as as
councillor welling said if if there is a
move from this council i mean it was the
first that we'd heard of it today that
that we are looking to install some ev
charging points at taxi ranks or on the
street or whatever
then again that piece of information
needs to
be um
you know out in the wider domain that if
it should should there be such such
infrastructure on the side of the road
um how do the taxi drivers feel about it
being mandated that they have electric
vehicles or whatever i mean i'm not here
to write a consultation question but it
does appear to me that there has been
maybe a lack of information sharing on
both sides really i mean maybe we as a
council aren't sharing what we're
thinking about doing with the taxi firms
themselves um and similarly how do we
know about this informal i i just have
my doubts about this informal
consultation we don't know who was asked
it could have only been the
one one particular demographic of taxi
firms who knows i don't think we should
assume council mansell that that the if
the responses to the informal
consultation were not recorded
i think i i think we should trust the
officers to have recorded that what i do
what does concern me is that that having
been
recorded
it wasn't passed on to
cabinet
so other
does anyone catch the cast i just i just
come back on that now i do i do agree i
just don't think that information was
massively important
but um i do i do feel this is a bit more
about
a um a license um
the cabinet have made a decision that
doesn't force
taxi drivers to go for electric and
hybrid cars and that's that's why we're
in here it's not about the information
that's on the um
and how the information was given to the
cabinet or anything so um
i that that's my problem with this
is that i think this is this is purely
a um
on that cabinet decision that doesn't
force people to go on to uh electric and
hybrids um and these details we're
getting caught up in the details did the
cabinet know that was that this
information there it's all just been
designed to get to the same place
well i mean my view is that
if if there was information about what
the effect of making it mandatory
would would be then that that
information
should have gone to
to cover it's not
in my in my mind
the discussion isn't whether or not they
should be mandated
to
change to
a hybrid or ev
i'm my concern is around the information
that was available to cabinet and i
think cabinet could have had more
information
counselor people
well i would agree with you to to an
extent uh
chairman um in in that did did the
cabinet have all the information
informal or otherwise
um to make their decision and i think
um
it would appear that you and i are going
to have to agree to disagree because
unless i'm mistaken i think cabinet was
aware of the informal
information as well as any other
information that they needed to make
their decision
and and and this calling is all about
did they make their decision
in in full
um
having full cognizance of all the
information available and i believe they
did
so
are you content that we go to a vote
um bear in mind
uh if we
can i i'll just say what i was gonna say
then i'll come to you emily bear in mind
if we do
vote to
refer this matter back to cabinet
the proposer and the second will have to
include in what they propose
the reasons why we're referring it back
to cabinet we can't just refer it back
to cabinet and say no more it's got to
be it's got to be clearly explained and
included
in the referral back the reasons for the
referral did you want to say anything
else emily
chair you just covered exactly the point
i was about to make thank you
so
i i guess somebody needs to propose that
we
do refer it back or somebody needs to re
propose that we don't refer it back
so
counselor ping on
mr chairman i guess it's pretty obvious
i'm going to propose that we do not
refer it back to cabinet
and i look for a seconder
and councilman willis seconds
right
so those in favor of
not referring it back
we have three are you happy to take it
by a show of hands
okay
okay so it's three in favor of not
referring it back those against
so that's three
and i believe i can use my casting vote
my casting vote
would be to vote
against not referring it back
so can i have a proposal then that we do
refer it back
we have uh councillor
mansell and councillor
scarf
so
this vote is that we refer it back
and at this point we've got we have a
proposal and a second or so we've got to
include
a form of words as to why we're
referring it back
um
i mean i i i feel that that it should go
back um with a
uh with some
further
after doing some further consultation
about
the
the concept of of mandating which
appeared to be not in the
current consultation but i'm not sure if
that is sufficient
reasons
um
i'm not quite sure what what we need to
put in in our reasons
um i mean my my view would be
yeah if we're going to refer it back we
can't instruct
further consultation we can
am i right we can we can say that
they should have been given say
information on the extent of the
pre-consultation or they should have
been given whatever
but i don't think we can instruct them
to carry out another consultation am i
right emily
um chair you can do both things so you
can
identify that you consider that the
cabinet didn't have sufficient
information on the form of the current
consultation and then as part of that
recommendation you could ask them to
carry out further consultation so you
can you can do both things um of course
it's a recommendation to undertake
further presentation and and it's about
um identifying which um parts of
information you feel that the cabinet
haven't um received sufficiently
so what was what what i said
is that there wasn't sufficient
consultation regarding
mandating
the move to um
low carbon or zero carbon choices
um and we recommend that further
consultation should go ahead
i mean am i is that the right sort of
thing to be said
no
do you want to include in that that
as you said earlier when you were
speaking debate that there's
that there should be an exchange of
information around
um off street
off street taxi ranks and
on and off street
um
charging facilities
are you both happy
does it would that's emily would that
satisfy
the requirements of a
um
of a call-in
chair both of those are valid grounds
for referring back and the only other
suggestion i would have is to actually
just go back to the call-in notice and
see if the committee wants to make any
specific points
in
response to the issues raised in the
call-in notice
shall we take a minute to look at that
there is a reference there isn't there
to the
um
the report to licensing and regulatory
committee
can i can i just commit it also does
mention this bit about they will look to
research and develop an incentive scheme
um
that that is mentioned in the call-in um
uh you know i presume we're happy that
that that that
does the provision of
um on an off-street charging facilities
is that part of an inven incentive
scheme or not does that come under that
remit
because if you know if there were more
charging facilities does that not add an
incentive anyway
well we could put uh if you see what i
mean and and other and other incentives
yeah i mean there may be incentives some
some councils have offered uh other
incentives different incentives
um and i wonder rather than being forced
to we we want to incentivize
rather than
other councils have talked about
mandates and forcing but
maybe incentivises
is a better term
and one of the things that was referred
to was um
that the um
the debate that was held
at
licensing was not
was not sort of fully reported in the in
the office's report that
it didn't give the indication at all
that
it was
as this might be carried on the
chairman's casting vote
um
it did
the the the the flavor of what was in
the report to cabinet was not quite the
same in my view as the flavor of the
debate
which was very very a very close call
how would that be put into the wording
of this recommendation then
um
more detailed information from the
um debate that took place at
license and regulatory
would that be okay
um i think um perhaps a more suitable
form of words would be that the
committee recommends that the cabinet
further explores the debate that was
undertaken by the licensing and
regulatory committee yeah um chair if i
may just in respect of calling point one
um obviously part of that talks about
the fact that there is no plan or
timetable presented around the incentive
scheme so the committee might want to
recommend that an action plan is
attributed to that
especially given that we've we've today
heard that they are already in
discussion with with providing some sort
of um
charging ranks or whatever um that to me
should be part of the information
sharing and that is part to me part of
the timetable of an incentive scheme
are you are you content as second uh
so
um i don't know emily whether you've got
a full wording or henriette or beth
yeah do do you want do you want to get
into a huddle to
to formulate the precise wording
yeah i don't think i don't think we need
we need to leave the room we'll just
we're just done
oh you're you're gonna leave the room
right those who need to leave the room
may leave the room but we should be back
in five minutes too
so we're now at the point where
the governance officer is going to read
out
the
motion that we are going to vote on so
it's a recommendation back to cabinet
and
one of you is going to read it out in
full
please thank you chair
members have um chosen to refer the
matter back to cabinet for
reconsideration together with the
observation of the ou scrooge committee
and cabinet will take a final decision
and that decision cannot be called in
the overu and scrutiny committee refers
the matter back to cabinet with the
following observations
that insufficient evidence of the
pre-consultation regarding mandating
conversion of vehicles to ev and further
consultation the trade is recommended
that cabinet needs further information
in respect of plans to provide on and
off street eb charging
that i plan sorry that an action plan is
needed to be agreed for the incentive
scheme as mentioned in
6.11 of the cabinet report
the cabinet needs to give further
consideration of the discussion of the
licensing and regulatory committee and
its reasonings reasons for recommending
the policy to cabinet
um can i just go first and i think
it's my fault henry
it should be
on street taxi ranks and on and off
street ev charging so
i left sorry i forgot the bit about
taxi ranks
council mansell
does that does that um include the um
the
future plans for on and off street taxi
ranks or whatever council williams just
called them all um to be shared with the
trade
as part of the consultation
you know in terms of
if if they know that we're planning to
do such things that that may change
their response on a consultation
possibly i don't know
could you just read out that sentence
for perhaps we need to put the word
consultation and information together or
information sharing or something like
that
just that one
that one sentence has got the word taxi
ranks and so on
that cabinet needs further information
in respect of plans to provide on and
off street tank taxi ranks and on and
off street ev charging
that only says that cabinet needs to
know about them
and i think that
as part of the consultation there should
be a bit of a two-way information
sharing
so shall we say following further
consultation with taxi
taxi providers
taxi and private hire providers
presumably you would like that to be
added
to the end of that sentence yeah
so
are we ready to vote on that
so those in favor of
the books
right okay i can't it won't work on mine
so um
if you can get the other you get the
vote from the other five the vote is now
in progress on one dot governor
sorry in progress yeah
but i but i can't i can't get down to
look at it where the screen won't move
down
i think it's something to do with a
broken hinge
can i take your vote
yes i mean i am in favor of the
calling back that's three votes four and
three against
and i will use my casting vote
to refer it back to cabinet
that's carried thank you
that is the end of
today's meeting and the next meeting is
just going back to check
it's on the is it the
21st of
monday
thursday thursday the 21st
monday the 21st of february sorry monday
21st of february
you